the chair recognizes the member from
Auburn representative Osborne who moves
at the house to Jour from the session of
February 22nd 2024 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the house is adjourned the house will
attend to a Prayer by house chaplain
Reverend Bob Stewart pastor of St Paul's
Manchester good morning Mr
Speaker good morning New Hampshire House
of Representatives morning let us
prepare our hearts for a moment of
prayer good morning
God on this day in these chambers of the
New Hampshire House of
Representatives we give you all the
glory and
praise oh Majestic God we know that you
are a god of love compassion and
peace make us a Channel of Your
Peace where there is hatred let us show
and share your love in ways that others
may see you through our
actions where there is despair in life
let us bring hope to others through how
we legislate change for our state and
for our
constituents God you are the alpha and
the Omega the beginning and the end the
first and the last be with each of us as
legislative business is presented before
this body
today help each of us to listen
carefully to each other so that we may
be able to make sound and careful
decisions decisions that will hopefully
lead to the betterment for all that will
be
affected and gracious God I once again
ask that you grant a special blessing
upon each member of this house
they work hard to do what is right for
the people of this great state of New
Hampshire and for that reason I ask that
you extend them your
grace God I also ask that you bestow
your blessings upon all the leaders
gathered here
today help them to lead in such a way
that it will be pleasing to you oh
God thank you God for your faithfulness
to us and may we enter be faithful to
you
amen the chair recognizes the member
from thoron representative Heather
Baldwin who will lead us in the Pledge
of
Allegiance Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for it stands one nation God indivisible
all the chair now recognizes Miss Louisa
siers a fifth grade student at
Waterville Valley Elementary School who
anthem oh say can you
see by the dawn early light what so
proudly we held at the Twilight last
gleaming who broad stripes and bright
stares through the peral of fight or the
ramp parts we watched were so
gallantly streaming and the rockets red
glare the bombs bursting in air gave Pro
through the night that our flag was
still
there oh s do that St Spangled
b
w or the land of the free and the home
brave
the house will attend to leaves of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Crawford Ellison McBeth
Montiel O'Brien Maria Perez Ryan sopus
Vincent the day important business
Representatives Balden Conlin McLean
Moffett O'Hara payer St Clair and
testerman the day illness in the family
representative
sandborn these leave some of absence
shall be granted unless otherwise
house the house will attend to
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Allan Susan and Kimberly rosson
Kelvin sors Morgan Brown and gunar
Baldwin friends and family of the singer
guests of Representative Baldwin Kira
wood and Peter vilon daughter and friend
of Representative wood Jade flad guest
of Representative Alan Reed Stephanie
grund guest of Representative AO and The
Honorable Tony Le Branch former member
from Amherst guest of Representative
Wendy Thomas there are with us in the
gallery
today Welcome to the New Hampshire
house
[Applause]
the house will now attend to the consent
calendar Mr Speaker from the committee
on legislative Administration house
resolution 25 removed by Representatives
Panic sers Christine Perez Tom Manion
yella are there any other bills to be
removed from the consent
calendar representative Osborne moves to
the consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in the day's house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppos nay the eyes have it and the
consent calendar is adopted the chair
recognizes the clerk Mr Speaker the
committee on enrolled bills has examined
found correctly en ruled the following
titled Senate bill Senate Bill 317
relative to establishing a New Hampshire
Ireland trade
Council recogniz the chair recognizes
the clerk again Mr spreer after
reviewing the bills assigned to finance
from last session I see no fiscal notes
with amendments on HBS 194 and 1294
therefore under uh house rule
47s F uh I'd be allowed to wave off
House Bill 194 and 1294 uh thank you Ken
Wier
the house will be attentive to motions
to suspend rules Mr Speaker
representative shirtliff moves that all
necessary house rules be so far
suspended as to allow late Drafting and
introduction of a bill relative to
requiring Presence at a sentencing
felony representative shirtliff is
motion thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise today to ask the house to suspend
their rules our rules so I can bring in
a late Bill and Mr Speaker I'd like to
answer three questions that this body
may have first being what do I know now
that I didn't know during the filing
period
secondly what would the bill be
about and lastly why this bill should be
passed now and not take taken up next
year by the new
legislature Mr Speaker 4 years and 3
months ago on December 7th
2019 Adam Montgomery beat his little
5-year-old daughter
Harmony but this time he beat the little
girl for the last time and ended up
killing
her then because the ground was
frozen he moved her body around a very
locations he ke he kept her little body
in an air shaft he put it in a cooler
kept in a hallway and then lastly he
kept it for the last month in a
commercial freezer when the ground had
th thought he
finally disposed of her
body what I didn't
know is under the state
law when a person is charged with with a
felony they do not have to appear at
their own
trial they don't have to appear at
right when I think of the
fact that the
prosecutor is filing a motion after Adam
McGary was found guilty last month to
ask the court to compel him to be
present for his May 9th
sentencing I said this isn't
right and I could think about this
horrendous
crime but I think about someone who was
a victim of fonia sexual
assault and we have a very strong victim
Bill of Rights in this state where
people have the right to either in
writer in writing or orally present to
the
court their victim statement
and I couldn't think of anything worse
for someone who has been a victim of a
crime to be presenting that statement to
the court and look at the defense table
and see an empty chair where the
perpetrator of that crime should be
sitting Mr Speaker what I would like to
bring in for a
bill and I would use the federal rules
of criminal procedure rule
43 which is the Federal rule that
requires all people charged with a
felony in federal court regardless of
the seriousness of the offense to be
there at their arraignment jury
selection trial and
sentencing what I would propose is not
as
stringent I would propose in a bill that
anyone charged in the granted state with
a class a felony and in New Hampshire we
have two classes of felony Class B where
you can get a year and a half to three
years incarceration or a Class A which
carries a penalty of 7 and a half to 15
years unless it's a capital offense and
then you're facing possible life class A
felonies
cover primarily our crimes of violence
from
murder
rape burglary arm
robbery
Asen
fonal sexual assault and the list goes
on my proposed
bill would require that person to be in
court during the judicial process it
would allow for either the defense of
the prosecution to file a motion with
the court on based on Just Cause for the
defendant to be absent or on motion of
the trial judge
themselves again I don't believe that it
should should be put off to next
year as I said the prosecutors filed a
motion with a court compelling Adam
Montgomery to be in court to face how
many's other family members and people
that that loved
her I don't know how the court is going
to rule but I ask you to grant me the
permission and to bring bring in a late
late bill so that it can file this bill
so that anybody charged with a class a
felony like Adam mcgomery will be in
Speaker the questions on the motion to
suspend the rules and this will be a
seats
e
[Music]
the question is on the motion to suspend
the rules and this is a division vote
please turn on your voting station
members are reminded to turn on their
if you're in favor of suspending the
rules press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
representative
bu
Philips have all members present had an
opportunity to vote motion passes the
house will attend to the state of the
vote 286 in the affirmative 67 and the
negative having reached the 2/3
threshold the motion is
adopted
the house will now attend to the regular
R
okay
the majority of the committee on
children and family law to which is
referred cacr 17 an act relating to the
rights of parents providing that parents
shall have a fundamental right to direct
the upbringing Education and Care of
their minor children having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Peter petrigno for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Mark
it the motion is inexpedient to
legislate representative cordelli is
motion
thank you Mr Speaker uh there is a long
history in this country about parents
rights let's start with the US Supreme
Court cases that date back almost 100
Years first one I'll mention is Pierce
versus the Society of sisters from
1925 let me quote from that decision the
child is not a mere creature of the
state those who nurture him and direct
his destiny have the right coupled with
the high duty to recognize and prepare
him for additional
obligations prince versus Commonwealth
of
Massachusetts for from
1944 it is Cardinal with us that the
custody and care and nurture of the
child resides first with the
parents just a couple of additional
cases 1972 Wisconsin versus Yoder 1977
1993 mention this one the 14th Amendment
forbids the government to infringe on
the fundamental Liberty interests of all
no matter who what no matter what
process is provided unless the
infrigment is narrowly tailored to serve
a compelling government interest we'll
touch on that
again Washington V versus gillburg
1997 Troxel versus Granville 2 th000 and
there are more I won't go into all of
them but the rulings have been
consistent that the due process clause
of the 14th of Amendment of the United
States Constitution protects the
fundamental right of parents to direct
the care upbringing and education of
their
children cac1 17 adds an amendment to
our Constitution's Bill of Rights right
under the right of privacy that we
passed and the public voted for in 201
18 this amendment does three simple
things three simple
sentences first sentence parents have a
fundamental right and responsibility to
direct the upbringing Education and Care
of their
children and the argument against that
is what the Supreme Court has ruled and
said that very same thing for
years the second sentence
neither the state nor any political
subdivision shall infringe on the these
rights without demonstrating that its
compelling governmental interest as
applied to the person is the highest
order and not otherwise served this
parallels a Supreme Court case of Reno
versus Flores which upheld the 14th
Amendment and said the same thing about
compelling government
ises third sentence the this article
shall not be construed to apply to a
parental action or decision that would
end the life or otherwise physically
harm a
child so it's not con con um giving
parental rights to parents to harm their
children specifically we are putting
amendment so why is this amendment
needed exhibit a the majority report is
exhibit a why this is
needed the majority report says that
this may enable parents to do things
like forcing children to quit school to
go to work or neglecting the proper
health care of their
children in effect it may enable parents
to be bad
parents evidently they did not read
sentences two and three of the
amendment that says specifically that
that parents are not allowed to cause
harm based on this Constitutional
Amendment they are also ignoring the
laws of New Hampshire that protect
children and there is sanowski versus
Kramer in
1982 uh Supreme Court case about the
minimal interests of the child which
read additional T attacks on parents
have been heard in this chamber and in
our committee education committee
repeatedly a few years ago here in this
very chamber there was a a bill related
to uh homeschooling that attacked
parents' rights who homeschool it was
said in this chamber that homeschool
parents sometimes want to homeschool
their children because they abuse their
children and this would hide the
abuse this week we had 4 to 500 parents
come to the education committee to talk
about their rights and another um attack
on their
rights this is
repeated this is why we need this
Constitutional Amendment uh in our um in
our
constitution please vote red to overturn
this itl motion because parents around
the state are watching and they want to
be able to vote vote on this and they
you Representative Patrick no is
report thank you Mr
Speaker
colleagues the majority of the committee
is opposed to this legislation not
because we are opposed to parental
rights because after all we're parents
and grandparents as well and we cherish
our rights no less than others but
because we know that parental rights
already exist they are well established
in federal and state statutes they have
been affirmed time and time again in
court
rulings and that this will not give
parents anything more than what they
already
have it has been repeated repeatedly
asked in committee hearings and
personally to individual members do
parental rights already exist and the
answer is always yes likewise will this
legislation give parents anything more
than what they already have and the
answer is
no we are doing our constituents a huge
disservice when we put forth legislation
which leads them to believe that they do
not have parental rights or that we're
going to bestow upon them rights which
they don't know they already have you
see it seems to me that the real issue
is that some parents believe that their
rights are being violated and that they
want
recourse the question then
is how do we address violations of
parental rights and we don't solve that
problem by simply restating the obvious
which is what this legislation does
instead we best serve our constituents
by being honest with them and directing
them
accordingly additionally while good
parents the vast majority are already
protected under existing laws and court
rulings the committee does fear that
some the few may feel falsely emboldened
to act in ways which are not in the best
interest of their children and puts them
In Harm's Way colleagues I ask that you
vote with the bipartisan committee
recommendation of inexpedient to
Speaker the questions on the motion have
been expedient to legislate on cicc1 17
this will be a division vote members
seats representative Sweeny requests a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
yeah it is this will be a roll call vote
seats
the questions on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on C7 seen and
this is a roll call vote representative
Mark Pearson's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that most parents are good parents and
that the ones they are the ones who
should have the primary role in their
children's upbringing and if I know that
this amendment would not interfere in
any way with
DCF and with the office of the child
advocate in their important roles of
safeguarding the physical and
psychological abuse in those cases where
parents are not good parents and finally
if I know that this amendment would
balance the scales between the rights
and responsibilities of the parents with
the rights and responsibilities of the
state would I not now push the red
button so that another motion may be
brought forth thank you Mr
Speaker representative Longs recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
the house rejected two bills addressing
like-minded issues last year and if I
know current statute enshrines rights of
parents with respect to their children
then would I press the green button
thank you Mr
Speaker the question is on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on cacr 17 and
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
e
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 174 in the affirmative 186 in the
negative the motion
fails representative Mark peeton moves
17 the Bill's on second reading and open
to further Amendment m m representative
Hull moves floor Amendment
13h which can be found in your seat
pockets and is recognized to speak to
his motion good morning
everybody the amendment before you is
simple it's one line versus three in the
original
bill it reads the fundamental right and
responsibility of parents to direct the
upbringing Education Health and Care of
their minor children shall not be
infringed
it's easy to make the argument that we
need to put all of those additional
constraints that's in the current bill
into our
constitution but we don't do that for
other
things you can still be prohibited to
own a firearm if you've committed some
egregious
act that creat that turns into a felony
or a misdemeanor with um a penalty of
greater than a year in
jail doesn't say shall not be infringed
with the exceptions of a bunch of
different things it says
says our fundamental rights for firearms
shall not be infringed same thing here
relative to
Parenting parents have the right to
direct the education and Welfare of
their children we know that this
amendment clearly states that if a
parent has done something so egregious
that they need to have their parent
their parental rights terminated that
still can happen in
statute we don't need to put that extra
Clause into the Constitution that will
create long-term legal battles that we
don't want I would ask that you would
you the questions on the adoption of
amendment
100038 are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
I hold up no you a request foris all
right this will be a division vote
seats
for
the questions on the adoption of floor
Amendment
13h this is a division vote if you're in
favor of adopting the amendment press
the green button opposed press the red
seconds
[Music]
representative
McKay
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 173 and the affirmative 189 and the
negative the amendment
fails now we're on to the motion of
ought to pass on cacr 17 and this will
also be a division vote so let's just
are
the question is the motion of ought to
pass on cacr 17 and it's a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
stations are
open
for
[Music]
[Laughter]
seconds
representative
bman
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house willena
the state of the
vote 180 in the affirmative 183 and the
fails okay uh bill on second reading
speak the committee on children and
family law to which referred House Bill
1006 FN an act relative to creating a
family access motion for the enforcement
of parenting plans having considered the
same report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Alicia Greg for the
committee the committee amendment is
04488 printed in house record 9 on pages
46 to
47 the questions on the adoption of the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppos
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted the bill is on second reading
and open a further Amendment
representative cab offers floor
Amendment
0553 which can be found in your seat
pockets and is recognized to speak to
our
motion thank you Mr
Speaker the floor Amendment just changes
one piece that was missed it was
redlined and
just uh missed by one of the drafting
attorneys uh it was a quick turnaround
time thing if you look in section
four uh part A where it says visitation
it was just changed to parenting time
and that's exactly how it should be so
this is one change just changing
visitation to parenting time and I ask
you to please support the floor
you the question is on the adoption of
floor Amendment 0553 H are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those opposed nay the eyes have it
and the Amendments
adopted now the question is the motion
of a to pass with amendments on House
Bill 1006 FN are you ready for that
question all those in favor say I I all
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
adopted
the majority of the committee on
children and family law to which was
referred House Bill 1189 an act relative
to criteria for reporting child support
delinquencies to federal agencies having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
Representative Patrick long for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that that the bill ought to pass
representative Deborah D Simone from the
minority of the
committee representative D Simone is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker Mr
Speaker unfortunately Society is filled
with
parents who don't take the financial
responsibility of their
children but there are more parents who
do take the financial responsibility of
those children
seriously House Bill 1189 was introduced
to the children and family law committee
for the simple
reason that a state agency isn't doing
the job they are tasked to do
properly we have many many
parents in this state who are working
hard and
voluntarily have their wages garnished
to make sure that their children are
heard testimony the New Hampshire Bureau
of Child Support Services
stated that it is tasked to accurately
report all aages in child support over I
repeat over
$2500 to the federal government and that
they
do what they don't do is report the fact
that someone has paid those aages and is
no longer in
aers or the aage is well under the $2500
$5 such was the case of the sponsor of
this
bill the committee heard testimony from
the New Hampshire Bureau of Child
Support Services concerning their
reporting process but when asked how
many people this action affect Ed the
answer
was
ready we don't currently have that
information
H when asked if they could get that
information the answer
was I'm not really
sure
H so this testimony led to some
committee members believing that this
bill was brought before us because one
one yes one person's
issue therefore they felt the need to it
this bill stating that they were not
going to legislate for just one
person
okay I and other members of the
committee found it very hard to believe
that that
one so one Committee Member came to me
and said can we file a
91a we talked about it for a while and
then thought we have an very able
committee
researcher why don't we ask her to do
the
research and our committee researcher as
able as she is did so the following
information that I'm going to read to
you was not available to our committee
at the time that we exec this bill it's
a
memorandum the subject was individuals
reported for child support of rear in
the last 24
months
question how many individuals in the
last 24 months have been reported to the
feds because they
meet met or exceeded $2500 in child
supportive re
12,087
one the second question was how many
individuals continue to be reported to
the FED after falling
below the $2500 in a rear
threshold but not at zero
OED so so to determine this number they
compared the total of number of
individuals
12,087 to the federal collections data
file on
13124 the total number of individuals
who continued to be reported and whose
$2500 which meant that they owed
1,037
people H that's not one person either is
it I do understand that the committee
did not have this information at the
bill so I think you can agree that these
numbers are staggering shocking and
personally I find it appalling that
these many people have been denied
passports listed as deadbeat parents
when they're really
not because what happens
is if you get paid every two weeks or
once a month inevitably you will be
behind at some point during the year
because of how many weeks there are per
month
it's not your fault you have
voluntarily had your wages
garnished the state is collecting that
money for every pay
period you're not voluntarily refusing
to pay child
support So ladies and gentlemen I ask
you to vote no on the itel motion so
that another motion can be brought
forward thank
you representative Grossman's recognized
Speaker good morning fellow
Representatives HB
11189 relative to criteria to reporting
child support delinquencies to federal
agencies is recommended inexpedient
to legislate after numerous discussions
based on the testimony of one
representative that tried to leave the
country but was denied because he came
up on the federal list for having an
aage of
$2500 the federal threshold for past due
child support which triggers a passport
denial yes
the Bureau of Child Support notifies you
it is up to individual
responsibility of the
paye to follow up once they've been
notified of their upcoming passport
denial
notice because of the past due Child
Support over
$2500 it is up to the
individual to work with the bureau to
remove their name from the federal
passport program once the file is
submitted and notification is received
of their failure to
pay we heard testimony from the Bureau
of child support that informed us that
case workers are trained to pick up
nuances of timing with payment
obligations there already is an
automated system in place
this legislation would require an
adjustment to the automated federal
reporting
system which would require a financial
appropriation which is not included in
this bill this would also Place Us in
Jeopardy of non-compliance with the
federal
requirements it's important that we
remember that we are talking about the
welfare and care of children and the
parental obligations we have when we
bring children into this
world please support the motion of
inexpedient to legislate vote green and
let's move on because we are not here to
legislate for our personal gains we are
here for the people of New Hampshire
thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill
1189 this will be a division vote
seats
e
the question is on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1189 and this is a division vote
representative Spain is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker members if
I know that uh there was an a will by
the chair of the committee to recommit
this to committee but that the time
frame that we're allowed Now does not
allow so because of the need to move
things to the other body and if I
further know that if we pass this today
and overturn the itl that the other body
will be able to fully vet this in a
public hearing with the new information
that was brought with well over a
thousand people who have been denied
passports when they never exceeded that
$2500
threshold because they're pay periods
lined up improperly with the weekly pay
that's required by the department and if
I further know that much of the
misinformation you heard in the
testimony from the itl side of things is
simply that misinformation and doesn't
take the facts of the cases into play
would I now push the red button to
overturn the itl so that an appropriate
motion could be made and this could be
heard in the other body thank thank you
representative Longs recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know New
Hampshire's automated Reporting System
reports a reage at 25 2500 and above and
if I know that reporting is done once
and it is up to the uh person in a reage
to straighten that out with them so they
wouldn't be continually reported and and
if I further know that house bill 1189
would require additional expense in
updating our system then would I press
the green button and support the
bipartisan uh committee
report the questions on the motion of
been expedient to legislate on House
Bill 1189 and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
representative
Bay
have all members presentence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 174 and the affirmative 191 and the
negative the motion fails representative
D Simone moves to pass representative D
Simone moves ought to pass are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I all those POs
adopted the committee on children and
family law to which was referred House
Bill 1263 FN an act relative to
Parenting coordinators in high conflict
cases having considered the same report
the same with the following Amendment
and the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass with Amendment
Representative Patrick long for the
committee the the amendment is
0476 H printed in house record 9 on page
62 the questions on the adoption of the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay the eyes have it and the
Amendments adopted now the motion is
ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 1263 you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppos
nay the eyes have it and the motion's
adopted
the uh a request
it the committee on children and family
law to which was referred House Bill
1266 FN an act relative to permitting
recordings of open Family Court
proceedings by parties having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Lori Bal for the
committee representative long has
recognized to speak against the
committee
report
thank you Mr Speaker House Bill 1266
allows recordings of open Family Court
proceedings by parties involved on its
face very reasonable uh it's limited to
involve parties
only would recording be from the table
where each party sits would the court
deem that disruptive it was stated in
testimony that someone else could re
record for a party this bill has no
mention of that with the party recorded
need to move from their front table and
addressing their devices if the judge
allowed it to be in the back of the
court is that disruptive private
Communications are not to be
recorded who would verify that the front
of the judge judges benches today audio
capabilities easily pick up the audio
also audio on private conversations with
opposing party can and would be also
picked up finally change of custody for
personal Pro say it's not a problem to
review their own video and audio uh and
helping them with their case however if
needed to be entered in the record as we
heard in testimony how would the chain
of custody be determined currently with
the Court's permission of recording can
be done by anyone a party in a
proceeding can invite someone they know
to record allow to to record allowing
for concentration on their procceedings
with the court approval the minority
believes House Bill 1266 would create
addition conflict between the parties
and the court and uh Mr Speaker I
request a division
vote representative balls recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker this bill
will allow parties to record proceedings
that are open to the public and Family
Division of the Circuit Court these
proceedings are already recorded by the
court and are available for p to the
public for a fee so where there is no
concerns about privacy sometimes the
Court's
proceedings excuse me sometimes the
Court's recordings of the proceedings
fails to record or stop stops partway
through the hearing in circumstances
such as this having a recording
available is extremely helpful
especially to those who do not have an
attorney and need to play back the
hearing to better understand the outcome
of the proceedings when they had
difficulty understanding the proceedings
while they were
happening this bill has narrowly
tailored is narrowly tailored to meet
the same requirements the court is
currently following except that it would
not require notice of intent to um to
record prior to the hearing the bill
prohibits the recording of private
communication of others including bench
and sidebar conferences conf conferences
between councel and conferences between
councel and client please help those who
cannot hire an attorney and find
themselves in Family Court by
you the questions on the motion of about
to pass on House Bill 1266
representative Granger request a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
quick housekeeping note members are
reminded that when someone's speaking at
the well avoid coming down the aisle
and for sure don't stop at the bottom of
that aisle to have a conversation in
speaking this is a roll call vote on
House Bill 1266 the motion is ought to
pass representative Grossman's
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know recordings are already
permitted in court with prior permission
therefore this legislation is
unnecessary if I also know that this
raises privacy issues for
children if I know that this bill would
raise concerns about how the Supreme
Court will decide which recording to
rely upon in appealed
cases and finally if I know that New
Hampshire legal assistance the New
Hampshire Coalition against domestic
violence and sexual violence end
Waypoint all gave us testimony against
this please vote no on hb1 1266 so that
another motion can be made thank
you representative D simones recognized
inquiry Mr Speaker thank you very much
for this
opportunity if I know that the previous
speaker is correct with prior
request you
can
um absolutely record the
proceedings but if I know that in some
cases people
don't have the time nor are they aware
that they can make that previous
request and if I know that
it is humanly impossible to remember
everything that is said in a courtroom
especially if you're nervous or
upset and if I finally know that it is
very important for all people to have
access to what is said about them and to
them in a court of
law then I would ask you to press the GR
green button and passed this very
important
legislation the questions on the motion
of ought to pass on House Bill 1266 and
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 191 in
the affirmative 173 in the negative the
the majority of the committee on
children and family law to which was
referred House Bill 1308 an act relative
to parent access to Children's Library
records having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Heather Raymond for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
committee the questions on the motion of
an expedient to legislate representative
quarello is recognized to speak against
the
motion thank you Mr
Speaker the purpose of HB
1308 is to allow parents to know what
library books their children have
checked out at both public and school
libraries currently Library circulation
records are considered confidential for
all users including miners the problem
with this law is reflected in a common
situation at library circulation desks
in which a parent pays an overdue fine
on a child child's account but the
library staff member cannot tell the
parent what book the fine is for aside
from practical problems with this law
there is a more fundamental issue that
reveals its
inconsistency the American Library
Association asserts on its website that
quote the parents role is to monitor his
or her child's individual reading life
end quote to fulfill their parental role
more effectively parents need to know
what books their children have checked
out this is especially important in
school libraries where parents are not
usually present with their children as
they often are in public libraries while
some children may not want their parents
to know what they are reading their
privacy rights should not extend to
their use of materials that they have
not financially contributed to parents
should be able to access their child's
Library records because as adults they
are the taxpayers who fund their school
in public libraries meanwhile this bill
does nothing to a child's right to
privately read whatever they want inside
the
Library HB 1308 has been criticized as
an unfunded
mandate this bill does require a library
to share all Library records regarding a
child's use of material if a library
however doesn't keep comprehensive
records of every book ever checked out
by P patrons all Library records would
just refer to the current books that are
checked out by the child this bill would
not require them to change this policy
there is no cost incurred to Simply show
apparent these existing
records regarding this issue I do have a
simple clarifying language to propose if
this itl is overturned and I am able to
offer a floor Amendment another
objection to this bill in committee was
that it would put a child in danger of
Parental abuse in order to implement
this law in the best interest of the
child's safety a library could mitigate
such a threat by having a policy of
asking for the parents driver's license
and making sure the address matches that
on a child's account it should also be
emphasized however that Library staff
are not the police it should be on the
onus the onus of the custodial parent to
bring any concerns about a potentially
Abus abusive parent to the attention of
Library staff just as they would inform
schools and teachers of such a situation
again the floor amendment I will offer
if the itl is overturned addresses this
issue and also remember that this
language could be further clarified on
the other side of the
wall in conclusion to improve Library
service and support parental involvement
in their children's reading Pursuits
please vote no on the itl motion so that
another motion may be made thank you Mr
Speaker and I request a division
vote representative Raymond's recognized
report thank you Mr Speaker a bipartisan
majority of the committee felt that this
bill was not practical and recommended
in expedient to legislate here are a few
reasons why currently most libraries in
New Hampshire and most libraries in the
United States do not not keep lists of
the books patrons have checked out for
longer than 30 to 90 days these records
are used only for the purposes of
assigning late finds and are typically
purged once the book is returned
libraries do have a catalog of materials
for the collection maintenance but it
doesn't include identifying information
of readers for any particular book so if
you or I wanted to get a list of all the
books that we personally checked out
last year we would find that it doesn't
exist there are currently no libraries
in New Hampshire that create or maintain
records of visitors internet history nor
visitors of of records of visitors
participation in activities and events
happening at the library this bill would
require libraries to create a recording
system for the activities and
information to that type of activity and
information in order to do that our
libraries will have to invest in new
databases and hire additional staff at
an unknown cost to local property
taxpayers
it's important to note that libraries
don't collect this data because of the
first and Fourth Amendment the Privacy
Act of 1974 and the 1998 children's
online privacy protection act there are
several US Supreme Court cases that
affirm the right to privacy when
accessing public
libraries the other concern of the
committee was that this bill can be
dangerous to abused and neglected
children and victims of domestic
violence it's common for the family
court to issue protective orders and
restrictions on access to records as
part of a custody agreement in cases
where there has been abuse neglect or
domestic violence by requiring libraries
to give information to any parent
without knowledge of custody orders it
creates a Gateway for abusive people to
access information that the court has
determined they are not legally entitled
to libraries are public facilities they
should not be put in the middle of
custody and parenting plans lastly it's
important to recognize that libraries
are public buildings not babysitting
Services one of the most fundamental
responsibilities of parenting is to
meaningfully connect with one's children
and guide them to developmentally
appropriate activities media and reading
choices that align with their own family
values parents who feel genuine
concerned about their children being
exposed to developmentally inappropriate
materials should be providing parenting
supervision while in the the library
parents who are concerned that their
older children are not responsible
enough to choose materials that align
with their family values already have
the option of simply not giving their
child their own library card and instead
have them use the parents library card
something to which the parent has
unfettered access for all of these
reasons I urge you to concur with the
bipartisan super majority of the
committee and press green to keep the
itl does the member yield for a question
yield the questions on the motion of in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1308 representative Granger requests a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the questions on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1308 and this is a roll call vote
representative Drago recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that
libraries already keep track of who
takes out a book and by adding one more
person on the record to know who can
take out a book does not create an
unfunded mandate and if I know children
at the age of six and in some cases five
are allowed to have a library card and
from that moment on parents do not have
access to what their child reads in
record
and if I know a parent is
responsible for their child's overdue or
lost book finds but they can't be
told what book they are actually paying
for and if I know that at the moment and
in in an individual makes a life choice
to start a family it's their right and
their right alone to raise a child how
they see fit and it's not a government
organization that can tell them
then you will join me in pressing the
red button so another motion and an
amendment can be
introduced representative Gregs
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill lacks the
understanding of our libraries current
abilities and funding for recordkeeping
and if I know that the cost of making
the necessary adjustments would be a
great cost to
taxpayers and if I know that it should
not be put on the Librarians to police
records access for complex family
Dynamics and if I further know that
parents are able to and strongly
encouraged by our libraries to accompany
their minor children in using the
resources therefore being able to help
guide and observe their own children's
choices would I not support the
overwhelming bipartisan committee
opinion on this bill and press the green
button
members are reminded to be in your seats
mode the questions on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1308 and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
representative
Schmidt
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 194 in the affirmative 170 and the
adopted the majority of the committee on
children and family law which was
referred House Bill 1392 an act relative
to consideration of the opinion of the
child in determining parenting time
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate Representative Patrick long
for the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Candace Gibbons for
the minority of the
committee representative Gibbons is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker uh this bill
uh I came up with over the summer
because I was going on a on a rabbit
hole down the internet and I was doing
some research so it's true that we do
already have in statute that the child
can testify as far as uh what what they
what their opinion is regarding
parenting time but we don't actually see
that in practice so I started going down
this Rabbit Hole to see why are we not
seeing this in practice um and I was
looking at Pub Med I was looking at law
journals and what I found out was that
it is considered traumatic for a child
to be brought into court stressful for
them and so that's when I started um
doing the research to come up with this
bill so if it's considered traumatic to
bring a child in to
testify and then the judge determines
that the child is not mature enough to
give their opinion then basically the
child was brought in created some trauma
and then and never had the opportunity
to give their testimony so I was like
well I I understand that that makes
sense to me so how can we fix this
so usually what they do is in situations
where the child's testimony wants to be
brought into the courtroom usually they
use uh you know someone like a guardian
at lium well the problem is that those
are not funded by the state and that's a
separate issue and if I'm reelected then
I can put in a bill that we can get
funding for Guardians at lium through
the state so basically what we end up
with is people who can afford a guardian
at lium have a guardian at lium who can
speak on behalf of their child people
who do not have a guardian at lium or
cannot afford one their child doesn't
get to speak so again you know I'm not
really just looking for problems I'm
looking for Solutions so how can we fix
this well if the child has a
therapist then we the therapist can just
write a little blurb about is the child
able to testify is the child mature
enough to testify if they do that then
we don't have to bring in the child for
the judge to do the assessment
piece we will bring in the report from
the uh from from the therapist telling
the judge that yes the child has the
maturity to be able to give their
opinion in court and as a side note I am
a fan of equal parenting time so this is
more this isn't so much for the child to
say like what parent they want to live
with it's not about that it's about you
know Billy
has uh you know Fridays that he wants to
go to uh Ste Steve's house that lives
near Dad and so he wants to spend
Fridays with his dad um but he'll still
want you know equal parenting time with
his mom so he might want other days with
his mom but that you know it's the
child's life so I think that the child
should be able to give their opinion
about how they want the 50/50 parenting
to look because there's so many
permutations on how 50-50 parenting time
can be exactly
crafted so if we were
to um have the child assessed by a
therapist uh to say that they're mature
enough to testify in court then we take
that assessment piece off of the judge
the judge can affirm the child is uh
mature enough to testify they don't have
to create any trauma on behalf of you
know of traumatizing the child by by
bringing them in when when they
don't have any gain you're only bringing
the child in if you
can get their opinion I hope that makes
sense um I would ask for you to vote red
against the
itl and I did present an amendment which
we can do next um to fix some of the
language thank you Mr
Speaker represent of Longs recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker I guess we
don't need family court it's child's
life let the child figure out what
when Hospital 1392 will require that the
court give consideration of a therapist
shall shall give consideration of
therapist to the child's report as to
the child sufficient maturity to to make
sound
judgment what's that relationship with
the child and the therapist is a report
from a single session did the did the
parent seek out a therapist that would
benefit their
outcome this bill doesn't qualify that
currently a court could determine to
interview the child the court May
interview the child this bill adds with
the consent of the parties that the
majority is of the opinion this the
majority is of the opinion that this
takes the discretion of the Court
Away by asking two parents that can
agree to agree and allowing an interview
with the judge simply creating more
conflict finally we have two adults that
are unable to agree on parenting time so
we'll ask the child to make that
decision I ask that you uh support I um
I I ask you I don't remember what this
was
I I I ask that you support the itl thank
you
the questions on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1392 are you ready for the question all
nay we're going to yeah yeah people
people not in no Whoa stop coming in
everybody back out people that were not
in the room when the question only
people in the room when the question was
[Music]
were as a clarification division
vote so nobody comes
in
[Music]
hey
okay this is a division vote this is a
division vote for the purposes of
clarifying The Voice
seats if you're in favor of an expedient
to legislate press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
seconds
[Music]
Che
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
again the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 219 and the affirmative and the few
no
the majority of the committee on
criminal justice and Public Safety to
which was referred House Bill 1527 FN an
act relative to Criminal Trespass having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is in expedient to legislate
representative Jason janen for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being an aable to agree with
the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Amanda Bolton for
the minority of the
committee well then representative
Phillips is recognized to speak against
report thank you Mr
Speaker um I see this bill as a Liberty
Bill property wrs and all of that I'm a
sponsor I think we should make it as
easy as possible for people to post
their land no trespass and other states
have adopted a purple paint flare on
trees to mark that as such uh this bill
uh would inform Hunters uh every year
when you get your license of the rules
and if the purple paint was adopted that
would be clear to
them uh this bill would not um change
people using the original signs to post
their land to allow for CrossCountry
skiers or other recreational activities
or you know allowing people to hunt
whatever they wanted to do they could
still use the signs this bill also has a
phase in of one year that if it were to
be
adopted um we would still need to use
the signage for the one year until we
inform the public of the
change I believe that this is not an
anti-h Hunter bill which is what some
people are uh saying this is this is a
property Rights bill and I'm just trying
to make it easier for elderly Property
Owners to maintain and post their land
by using a can of spray paint that kryon
already prints it's purple and uh
marking their trees as such if they want
a no trespass on their land I think that
the educ the public is smart enough to
figure it out once it's employed here
just like it is in other states and I
have no problem supporting this it's a
liberty bill please vote against itl so
that another motion can be made thank
you representative pretend is recognized
report there are a lot of people in here
that hate the hypocrisy we see quite
frequently in arguing for or against
legislation in this chamber and in our
committees that is the reason why I'm
speaking to overturn the itl so the
majority of arguments that I've heard
from my
side of the aisle are about Bad actors
that will Mark people's private property
those same Bad actors can easily post
signs too so do we infringe on the
Second Amendment and take law abiding
citizens firearms because of Bad actors
no the gun doesn't operate on its own
and neither does the paint can so if you
research purple paint laws you will find
the majority of the states that have
these in place lean
conservative a republican helped draft
this bill and it actually does have some
bipartisan support so I stand with
property owners having options this bill
allows Property Owners to mark their
property with no trespass paint or signs
it doesn't require anybody to do
anything it gives people options so if
we're going to uphold the constitutional
principles for the rights of gun owners
then property owners deserve the same
part one article two natural rights we
all have the right essential inherent
rights are enjoying and defending life
and Liberty acquiring and possessing and
protecting
property so I'm going to just read one
quote and I'll be done this law this is
some from someone that's in a very
conservative State isn't just in place
to keep land owners in their cattle safe
it also assists assists busy farmers who
cannot keep an eye on their land borders
farmers can easily Mark trees around
their land in a cost effective way
rather than taking time and money to
invest in property signs that may not
last very long please vote red against
the itl for another motion to be
presented thank you
representative Muse has recognized speak
report uh thank you Mr Speaker U I guess
you could sum up my remarks uh basically
by uh just saying what she said and what
she
said
um our committee has heard variations of
this bill for the past couple of
sessions uh in the online testimony
submission system we had 60 people who
signed in and supported this bill and 16
who signed in and against it and I know
a lot of folks in this room I'm not one
of them I represent a city but I know a
lot of the folks in this body represent
towns and so when I actually looked at
where the people were from who were
signing in in support of this bill I'm
not seeing towns like Manchester and
nsha and Portsmouth what I am seeing are
s towns like Stoddard Benton Dalton
Auburn Deering Claremont Newton Webster
New Boston Alton I could go on this is a
bill that your constituents want uh
another thing I would just remind
everyone of is I I know this has been
framed as a as a property Rights bill
but in many ways this is also a bill
that's about privacy um we' we've
actually in this body we think so much
of the right of privacy we've actually
enrin it in our state
constitution um this is a bill that
simply would allow more people to
exercise that right in a way that works
for them thank
you representative Roy is recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker um I really
got tag teamed on that one um so here's
the
concept everything everyone said is most
mostly true it it will make it easier to
post your
land um although fishing game testified
in front of our committee that if you
want your property posted they'll come
out and do it for
you why would they do such a thing so
that they can help maintain the deer
herd they want good relations with
Hunters fishing game was against this
bill now and all honestly I I'm the one
who actually helped write the bill a
year ago because I thought it was a good
idea when I heard it
however like many ideas once you
research it more and more you learn more
about it so the question is it really
put aside the hunting and the rights and
the trespassing let's get down to our
fundamental what we believe as a state
this state in the 1600s when we founded
it and populated it came from England
where if you killed a deer that was on
the king's land you were executed it was
the king's property he didn't care if
your children were starving if you went
and tried to trespass on his land and
collected animals to feed your family
you were
executed so our Founders said we're not
going to do that anymore we're going to
share this land so New Hampshire was
founded on a concept of shared land it
doesn't mean you can't post your
property but they did make it so you had
to take an extra step to do so so that
the initial implication was baring
everything else you were going to share
your lands
so what this bill will do it makes
halves and halves not if you don't own
land and you can't find somewhere
without purple paint you can't hunt so
most of the hunters in the state
actually don't own land so what you're
doing is you're eliminating this for
people who don't own property so we hear
this you know we're supposed to be a
free state but we hear a lot of people
saying well it's my property not in my
backyard I'm going to paint that you
stay away is that what we stand for as a
state because that's really what this
bill is about are we still a state that
we value sharing with our neighbors The
Great Outdoors of this state or are we
going to put up walls and borders and
protect our own little fom and no one
else can come in so I ask you to think
about that when you cast this vote do
you want to share do you want to change
the culture of this state from one that
was founded on sharing the land to one
that's just for me and nobody else I
would ask you to support the itl thank
you does a member yield for a question
not the question is on the motion of
inex speeding to legislate on House Bill
1527 and a division vote has been
seats
e
the questions on the committee report of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1527 and this is a division vote
representative harri G recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I know
one not one land owner appeared in
opposition to hp1
1527 wherein in the past before the
changes they filled the criminal justice
publicy seats hearings against purple
paints Mr
Speaker if I know I have never voted for
purple paint in the previous years
because of the testimony of the owners
however today I like the idea that the
owners have the option they do
too and Mr Speaker and since I know that
this bill is not mandatory and the
owners have the options to use the signs
or the purple paint as well as both I
would vote against the it motion so that
another motion is offered thank you Mr
Speaker representative rhs is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know we don't have to have the
public to show up to tell us that a bill
is
bad and Mr Speaker if I know that the
citizens of New Hampshire have always
felt that the land of New Hampshire was
Majestic and therefore it should be
shared and that if I know if a person is
having any difficulty posting their land
or if they don't want to share their
land at all they don't have to and Fish
and Game will come help them post it and
if I know Mr Speaker that the last two
Farm Bureau meetings that the
legislators were invited to in cheser
county that they expressed their
Exquisite opposition to this bill would
I now press green to vote with the
committee the questions on the committee
report of in expedience to legislate
anoun Bill 1527 and this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 202 in the affirmative 161 in the
the committee on education referred
House Bill
1437 relative to the membership of the
State Board of Education the bill comes
recommendation representative Tanner
moves out to pass and and offers
Amendment
0666 H printed on house record 9 on page
67 the questions on the adoption of the
amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppose
nay
who we're going to do a division vote to
seats
okay the questions on the adoption of
amendment 066 H if you're in favor of
the amendment press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
not
can't
[Music]
rhods
represent
Le
have all members present had an opport
opportunity to vote good example of why
being in the room is important the house
vote 178 in the affirmative 176 and the
adopted now we on a to pass as amended
on House Bill
1437 representative belsh is recognized
motion thank you Mr Speaker good morning
colleagues there's really three points
you need to understand about this bill
and I won't belabor them the first point
is we heard testimony in committee that
when this when this board of education
was established it was purposely meant
to put everyday regular New Hampshire
citizens in a regulatory and oversight
role of
Education this would put professional
Educators for the first time on this
Point these it's generally considered
unethical and bad practice not best
practice to allow people who are
professionally involved in an
organization or or in a field to
regulate what they are involved with we
don't put Bankers in charge of ready
vinkers or at least we shouldn't we
don't put healthc Care Professionals who
are active in the field involved with
regulating themselves it's not a best
practice the third and final point I
will make and this I think really says
quite a bit if I can paraphrase the what
we received an executive testimony from
the ranking minority member of the
committee who put it very bluntly he
said the Board of Education as it
currently exists is far right and this
bill is necessary to bring it to the
left please oppose this vote no thank
you I request a roll call
speaker representative Chan has
motion thank you Mr
Speaker HB 1437 is a bill that
modernizes the State Board of Education
that was formed in
1919 to meet the demands of our present
day educational system in 1919 the
legislature and the governor realized in
order to cherish education as directed
in our
constitution the education system of
that time needed to make some drastic
changes the system needed to expand uh
from the urban areas into the rural
areas and the state needed to take the
lead in providing educational guidance
and oversight of standards and programs
to bring all children an opportunity of
an education and an educated
citizenry in response to the need that
need the position of Commissioner of
Education along with the State Board of
Education to act as a Board of Trustees
was created the newly formed
Commissioner of education required a
person with training and experience in
educational work and the board was would
complement this executive position and
be comprised of five citizens from dis
uh diverse backgrounds further there
would be no more than three of the five
members on one party and no technical Ed
educator persons professionally engaged
in schoolwork could
serve the composition and duties of the
New Hampshire State School Board of have
changed several times over the past 125
years eliminating some of the
regulations and duties while expanding
others and increasing the membership to
seven by adding two at large
members in hp1
1437 addresses the need for changes in
the composition of the State Board of
education that now has a tremendously
expanded responsibility for decisions of
today's State education system currently
the board oversees roughly 295 private
schools serving two 28,000 students 495
Public Schools serving about
169,000 students um
4,700 EFA students with
13,500 certified teachers plus
administrators and
staff today's State Board of Education
deals with complex issues like academic
and minimum standards teachers
certification and training building Aid
Charter Schools remote learning Extended
Learning opportunities funding for
special education adequacy credentialing
and the state's obligation in school
funding just to name a few they are
responsible for regular reviews and
reports for all the programs and
activities that of the Department of
Education they advised the commissioner
regarding departmental goals information
gathering and un other aspects of
Elementary and secondary education they
are charged with hearing appeals and
issues making final decisions on rules
made by the department adjudicating any
disputes between individuals and schools
or the Department of Education approving
charter schools and many other
responsibilities the issues in education
at all levels have increased
tremendously the educational system has
become more complex and requires a great
deal of attention input and experience
from a wide range of
areas presently there are seven
positions on the State Board of
Education the five positions are
designated one each uh to each executive
Council
position and they were in the original
membership in 1990 the current board
also has two members that serve at large
our surrounding New England states have
expanded their membership of their
Boards of Education to provide enough
coverage for all these responsibilities
and allow for formation of subcommittees
for studies and
reports these New England states have
also included more diversity by
including stakeholders like parents
Health Care Professionals educational
leaders from colleges and universities
students as well as members of of the
education system HB
1437 seeks to increase the board to 11
members with one non-voting student
member as well the current membership of
the five members one from each executive
Council district and the two at large
will remain as stated but the amended
part will be the proposed new membership
which will include a retired public
school classroom teacher two parents of
public scho school students one member
from the New Hampshire administrators
Association and a student who serves in
a non-voting position the bill removes
the Restriction of not allowing anyone
who is a technical educator to serve on
Boards of other professional
organizations such as doctors doctors do
serve on those boards um these major
changes allow input from stakeholders
who will bring their Insight experience
and knowledge to the State Board of
Education to re represent and be
responsive to a cross-section of all New
Hampshire citizens who are interested
and involved in our educational
system these changes will bring our
state board of education new input and
energy needed to meet all the many
responsibility and will provide guidance
and advice to to prepare New Hampshire
students for their future and to meet
the challenges of the 21st century and
beyond I urge you to vote a to pass
and I ask for a division vote thank you
does the member yield for a question no
yield the questions on the motion of V
to pass as amended on House Bill 1437
representative belshire requests a roll
call vote is that sufficiently
seconded yep is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
C
the questions on the motion of V to pass
as amended on House Bill
1437 representative lad is recognized
inquiry thank you very much Mr
Speaker if I know this bill will up in
the historical intent and the balanced
membership of our state board of
education if I also know it would place
professional Educators administrators on
that state
board in conflict with an opinion of the
justices written in
1973 that states and I will quote
members of the Board of Education shall
not be professionally engaged in school
work and if I further believe this bill
will result in total conflicts of
interest on the state board would I then
keep the State Board in its present
composition of seven state board members
and by pressing that green button to itl
this
button that's why we ask representative
Damon recognized for parliamentary
inquiring
thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the roles and
responsibilities of the State Board of
Education have a broad impact on our
education systems and quality and if I
know that hb1 1437 creates a much more
informed board membership by including
members with direct knowledge and
experience in our schools but maintains
a majority of non- educator
members and if I know that the chair of
House Education routinely respects and
refers to Educators for Testimony in our
committee and if I know that a strong
education system is essential to the
well-being of our society would I now
press the green button thank
you the questions on the motion of ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 1436
7even and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 176 in the affirmative 190 and the
negative the motion
fails represent uh for what reason does
a member rise I I move indefinitely
postpone House Bill
1437 representative Sweeney moves to
indefinitely postpone House Bill
1437 are you ready for the question yeah
I thought so this will be a division
vote members should already be in your
seats MERS in your seats all righty if
you're in favor of indefinitely
postponing press the green button oppos
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
Gil
you of all members presence had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote one 93 in the affirmative 173 in
passes the committee on education the
wishes referred House Bill 1695 relative
to the release of student personally
identifiable information comes to us
without recommendation representative C
Deli moves out to pass and offers
Amendment
06418 printed in house record 9 on page
70 the questions on the adoption of the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
fose nay the eyes have it and the
Amendments
adopted now the motion is ought to pass
representative bbon is recognized to
motion thank you Mr
Speaker HB 1695 concerns a very
important issue student privacy and the
protection of student personally
identifiable
information clearly maintaining student
privacy is of the utmost importance and
school districts are required to follow
state and federal laws designed to
protect this
information as well as ensure that any
contracted providers comply with New
Hampshire student data privacy
regulations usage of personally
identifiable
information already requires parental
consent and is heavily regulated through
the family educational rights and
Privacy Act New Hampshire
rsas and the Department of Education
minimum standards for privacy and
security of student and employee
data
further school districts participate in
the New Hampshire data privacy
Consortium and only work with vendors
who can meet the standards for
maintaining data privacy
y each year school districts provide
parents with information about federal
state and School District policies and
procedures and parents must sign a
notice acknowledging receipt of this
information parents have the opportunity
to opt out of sharing even minimal
directory
information I additionally parents of
students receiving special education
services through a contracted service or
thirdparty provider must provide written
consent for the provision of these
Services if the permissions are not
received then generally third parties
cannot receive student
information there is no evidence that
school disc that school districts are
not complying with student privacy laws
however this bill seeks to add another
layer of bureaucracy and will require
school districts to provide specific
written notification to parents each
time personally identifiable information
is transferred from school districts to
third
parties the language in this bill does
not make it clear whether all data or
addressed does a teacher need to not
notify the parents each time student
progress is shared with a contractor
specialist such as a speech and language
therapist what does this mean for
communications with the many contracted
nurses filling in for school vacancy
School nursing
vacancies is written notification
required to provide the names and
addresses of students to to third-party
Transportation
vendors the language of
1695 does make it clear that teachers
will be required to spend additional
time on administrative
tasks this legislation is not
necessary it does nothing to enhance
student privacy
protections we often hear in our
committee that school districts pay too
much for administrative costs so why do
we keep putting more clerical costs I'm
sorry more clerical tasks on their
plate let Educators spend their time
helping students
learn I urge you to vote no on the
motion about to pass so that a new M
motion can be made and Mr Speaker I ask
vote representative cordelli is
recognized to speak for the
motion thank you Mr Speaker the family
education rights and Privacy Act furpa
is a federal law that gives parents the
right to have access to their children's
educational records the right to seek
amendments to the records and the right
to have control over the disclosure of
personally identifiable information from
those records under furpa a parent shall
provide written consent before a
district can disclose student personally
ID identifiable
information however there are
exceptions under fural law 34f FRN
9931 the school can disclose information
under circumstances including to a
school official or teachers with a
legitimate educational need but also
also to a contractor or consultant who
performs services for the school that
school staff might otherwise perform
it's okay to disclose cons information
to them without paranal
consent we can't do much about the
federal
law
the majority
report says that this would violate uh
information sharing in federal law but
it does not it clearly states that
um is not contrary to federal law all it
does is let parents know when
confidential student information is
being released to a third
party we have great concern about
student privacy rights in our
Constitution and I know well about the
requirement to let parents know about
furpa because I wrote the
law this bill is very simple it just
says that when information is released
parents must be notified when it is
released what information is being
released to whom it's being released and
why the amendment just clarifies that
the amendment that we just passed
clarifies that this not does not apply
to information transfers between
districts and school
districts we have already had a parents
rights piece of legislation defeated
today and now we're hearing that
notifying parents is just another level
of
bureaucracy really you there is no there
are no penalties in this bill and no
enforcement because federal law allows
it but shouldn't parents know what's
going on and what information has been
given out to other
vote the questions on the motion of
ought to pass on House Bill 1695
representative cordelli requests a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the questions on the motion of our to
pass as amended on House Bill 1695 and
this is a roll call vote representative
Hall is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the privacy and security of
student data is highly regulated through
federal and state laws as well as in New
Hampshire doe standards and if I know
that New Hampshire school districts
charter schools and private schools
belong to the New Hampshire student data
privacy Consortium whose primary goal is
to address data privacy in schools and
furthermore if I know that this
legislation is not needed as it would
provide no additional data privacy to
students and would place an unnecessary
burden on School District employees
would I now push the red button so that
another motion can be made thank
you representative Pell's recognized for
inquiry Mr Speaker if I know that
article 2B of the New Hampshire
Constitution states an individual's
right to live free from government
intrusion in private or personal
information is natural essential and
inherent if I know that under fura rules
a school can disclose confidential
student information to third parties
without their parents' knowledge if I
know that this bill does not violate
furpa and merely requires
notification and if I know that a parent
parent has a right to know when their
children child's information has been
disclosed would I now vote ought to pass
and press the green
button the questions on the motion of V
to pass as amended on House Bill 1695
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button oppos press
seconds
[Music]
I present gr
me have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attenda the state of the
vote 192 in the affirmative 173 in the
adoped
Granger the majority of the committee on
environment and agriculture to which is
referred
ca14 an acts relating to the environment
and natural resources providing that the
state shall maintain and improve a clean
and healthful environment for present
and future Generations having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legis slate
representative Jim kryon for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having in said the same
and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Nicholas jman for the
committee representative formano is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report
Speaker the primary concerns that were
raised regarding this proposed
constitutional amendment in our
committee had to do with the the claim
that the language in the proposed
amendment is vague well I would submit
Mr Speaker that this is the very nature
of fundamental rights statements of
fundamental rights are always by nature
vague if we had before us in this body
today the First Amendment to the United
States Constitution or the second
amendment I think we would make the same
claim that they are vague that's why we
spent more than 200 years legislating
and litigating in order to debate to
Define and to protect those fundamental
rights likewise with our own New
Hampshire Constitution it requires that
we Prov provide an adequate education
for the children of this state we all
know how long it's taken us to get to
where we are now where we still can't
Define what it means to require an
adequate education for the children of
our state Mr Speaker I submit that not a
single member of this body would
therefore conclude that it shouldn't be
a constitutional right simply because we
struggle to continue to Define
it we weren't born
being able to speak and yet both the
United States Constitution and the
constitution of the State of New
Hampshire protect our right to free
speech certainly none of us was born
with a gun in our hands and yet the
Second Amendment and the New Hampshire
Constitution defend our right to bear
arms each and every one of us was born
needing to breathe clean air and to
drink clean water and to eat produce
that comes from clean land there simply
is no right more fundamental than the
right to a clean
environment one of my colleagues in the
committee raised a good point one with
which I do not
disagree he suggested that an amendment
like this exists in order to invite
lawsuits as we have seen for example in
the state of
Montana and my response is that's right
because that is how we debate and
defined and defend fundamental rights is
through our court system and through
bodies such as
this we talk about the financial deficit
avoiding deficits the irresponsibility
of the financial deficit that is accured
in
Washington so my question Mr Speaker
today is what about the moral deficit
what about our
responsibility as steward of the
environment to our children and to our
grandchildren like most of my colleagues
in this body I am a parent like many of
my colleagues in this body I am a
grandparent and I know that there is
nothing that I wouldn't give including
my life to stand between my children or
my grandson and imminent
danger and I'm confident that that is
true of every parent and every
grandparent in this body
well I suggest that we are I do more
than suggest we are facing imminent
danger now 2023 was the hottest year on
record and it is likely to be the
coolest year of the rest of our
lives there is imminent danger now and
we refuse when we refuse to take action
we are refusing to accept the moral
responsibility that we have to fure
future
Generations I ask my colleagues in the
house to uh vote to overturn the itl so
that we can begin to accept the
responsibility that we should have been
accepting for a long time now and allow
you representative katton recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker
fellow Representatives I rise in support
of the environmental and agriculture
committee 13-7 bipartisan recommendation
of itl on CAC
R14 the committee confirmed the vital
importance of protecting our environment
but felt that the language in C cacr 14
would not serve to enhance our efforts
to improve the grant State
environment Grant state is dedicated to
improving our environment without this
Constitutional
Amendment this body continues to
consider bills on Pas on water safety
landfills and many other environmental
concerns the Department of Environmental
Services the mission statement is to
protect I quote to protect and wi the
protection and wise management of the
state's environment are the main goals
of the agency other states have enacted
Constitutional Amendments similar to
this they've resulted in
unforeseen suits second and third or
effects that have been more detrimental
than than
supportive the committee voted 13 to7 in
support of itl and looks forward to
taking action on concrete legislation to
protect our environment I urge you to
support the committee recommendation and
much the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on cacr 14 representative
Granger requests a roll call has that
sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the questions on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on CAC
R14 representative Horgan is recognized
inquiry the house will be in order thank
you very much thank you very much Mr
Speaker so I'm representative for pi a
series of rhetorical questions but
before I do that I I may point out the
last time I participate in floor fight
over cacr the speaker who was then
speaker Chandler to um actually had to
cast a vote so you may actually have to
use your button and I'll tell you which
button I think you should press if that
happens M thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that we the people of New Hampshire V
always had a strong connection to the
Earth as shown by the fact we call
ourselves Granite Staters after the uh
rock that bed rock that underlies um
almost the entirety of our
state if I know that we the people of
New Hampshire have always understood the
importance of passing on a clean and
healthful environment to Future
Generations so our grandchildren's
grandchildren grandchildren can continue
to live free long after we all
die and if I know that there's a good
reason to be confident that a 2third
super majority of our fellow uh of our
fellow citizens I we the people of New
Hampshire will be more than happy to
affirm these principles by voting for
CAC 14 in November I think it's November
5th
okay
then would I and possibly you Mr Speaker
but would I then press the red button to
overturn the pending motion of itl to
allow an alternative motion to be
considered that would be the red
representative colons recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know cacr 14 was copied and pasted
from Montana's Constitution where it's
caused a hail storm of litigation and
judicial
interpretation and if I also know
measures like this could call into to
question things like driving gas
powerered
vehicles eating
meat burning firewood and a laundry list
of other things essential to living free
in New Hampshire and finally if I know
there's more fruitful ways of being
better stewards of our environment than
adding more words of art to our
constitution would I please hit the
green button to maintain its Integrity
thank
you the house will be in
order the questions on the motion of
inexpedient to legislate on cacr 14 and
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button oppos press
seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 197 in the affirmative 168 in the
speaker Mr Speaker
nothing for what reason doesn't member
rise Mr Speaker I move that the debate
on CAC R14 be placed in the permanent
journal without that
ordered the majority of the committee on
executive departments and administration
to which is referred
cac1 an act relating to the retirement
age for sheriffs providing that sheriffs
attaining the age of 70 years during
their elected chman office shall be
permitted to complete their current term
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative Jackie groa for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Sher G for the
minority of the committee the questions
on the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legisl are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose nay no the eyes have it
adopted the majority of the committee on
Fish and Game and Marine Resources to
which was referred House Bill
1029 and act relative to exempting
certain persons from requiring a New
Hampshire Landing license if such
persons are not Landing for the purpose
of the sale of the lobster or crab they
have caught having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is an
expedient to legislate representative
kathern Harvey for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following amendments and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment represent ative
committee representative kofalt is
recognized to speak against the
committee
Speaker as legislators we're called upon
very often
to look at a particular scenario
consider all of the permutations that
might happen and come to a decision as
to how those should be handled once in a
while there's something we don't think
of and this bill pertains to one of
situations imagine that you enjoy the
outdoors you have a uh a non-resident
license to uh to catch Lobster and crabs
in
Massachusetts but you have a home on the
Sea Coast and you have a boat there you
take your boat out for the day
you go down to Massachusetts uh maybe
pick up some friends do some lobstering
Lobster now you bring it back pull up to
the
dock and as you start to take the
lobster on the off the boat you realize
you have a
problem in order to carry that Lobster
from your boat to the dock and on to
land you need a landing license
you need a commercial Lobster Landing
license there is no non-commercial
version of this you need a commercial
Lobster Landing license the cost of that
license is
alternative before you come back to New
Hampshire Waters you could pull your
boat into a Massachusetts
Port call up Uber on your mobile phone
Drive the lobster back to New Hampshire
get back in the Uber drive back to your
boat
and go
home that probably cost you less than
the $500 that it will cost you for a
landing
license this bill simply removes that
Landing license requirement for anyone
who is harvesting lobster for non
non-commercial
purposes now you will hear objections
that um the the uh federal government
needs to track the the statistics with
regard to the catch if you have a
non-resident Mass Massachusetts
lobstering license you are already
Massachusetts so this bill simply
removes what I believe is is an
oversight kind of a bureaucratic snafu
that leaves some people in some
situations with that dilemma do they
break the law do they pay pay $500 or do
they jump through hoops um to try to get
their lobster back uh back home I urge
my colleagues to vote no so that a new
motion can be brought forward thank you
Mr
Speaker representative Darby's
report thank you Mr thank you Mr Speaker
lobsters are the most valuable
commercial Fishery for New Hampshire
providing more than $34 million annually
in revenues to commercial fishermen with
a tech total economic impact to the
state over $400
million but lobsters are at risk the
catch has been on decline lately and the
2023 Harvest was the lowest since
2009 even more alarming young lobsters
stocks have declined almost 40% in
recent years its clear management of
this important economic resource is
essential to maintaining healthy stocks
to support the vital Lobster
fishery the house bill 1029 undermines
the management process by eliminating
the reporting of recreational Lobster
catch landed in New Hampshire but taken
outside of the state such as federal
waters and from nearby States since
lobsters are a migratory
species they are managed by the
interstate fishery management plan for
American lobster which requires
reporting of of lobsters in the states
where they are brought
ashore New Hampshire fishing game uses
Landing permits for the for this
reporting required by Rec excuse me
required by recreational Lobster
fisherman without a New Hampshire
license unlike my colleague from fishing
game um uh mentioned to you the New
Hampshire cost New Hampshire resident
cost for a landing license is $50 which
can be reduced to $40 if they choose
instead to buy a recreational lober
license the $500 is for a non-resident
there are no adjoining states that offer
non-resident Landing permits New
Hampshire is the only state so this
isn't even reciprocal for
$500 further as the fishing game
department is self-funded a loss of
revenue from permits reduces the funds
available for the Department's other
critical Resource Services such as
rescuing stranded hikers and emergency
services for snowmobile and oh
[Music]
accidents New Hampshire fishing game
opposed this bill stating it would
hamper their ability to meet the fishery
management plan's requirement to
accurately report the lobster landed in
the state they also describe challenges
in trying to differentiate recreational
and Commercial fishermen from other
states numerous commercial fish Lobster
fishermen including the Yankees
Fisherman's Cooperative also testified
it against it over lack of reporting
poaching potential and enforcement
concerns the bill is
introduced is even more problematic than
an a proposed amendment potentially even
permitting lobsters to be taken by
diving I ask you to support New
Hampshire lobster fisherman and New
Hampshire fishing game's responsibility
to track and manage The crucial resource
by voting in favor of the committee's
bipartisan recommendation of inexpedient
to legislate by pushing the green button
thank you Mr Speaker and I ask for a
division
vote questions on the commy report of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1029 representative hle request a roll
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the questions on the committee report of
in expedien to legislate on House Bill
1029 representative Carol Brown's
inquiry uh thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker if I know that it is allowable
for New Hampshire residents to catch
lobsters or crabs recreationally in
federal waters and if I know that these
lobsters are crabs cart recreationally
are only intended for personal
consumption not commercial sale if I
also know that currently a New Hampshire
resident must purchase a landing license
in order to bring those lobsters home
for his own his or her own personal
use and finally Mr Speaker if I know
that regardless of the price of that
Landing license that Li license is an
unneeded tax on the person who catches
Lobster and crabs for their own personal
consumption therefore what I then press
the red button so that another amendment
can be made thank
you representative Harvey's recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill would eliminate
the reporting process for lobsters taken
outside of the state for recreational
purposes and if I know that that
reporting process is actually required
by the interstate management plan for
American
lobsters if I know that it is the duty
of New Hampshire fishing Game
Commission to set the rules regulations
and fees for all
licensing and if I know that having
attended a New Hampshire fishing Game
Commission
meeting the commission is now looking at
this very issue as we
speak concerning fees and
regulations and if I know that a
non-resident Landing license for
recreational lobsters is $50 not $500
would I now press the green button to
support the the workings of the New
Hampshire fishing Game Commission as
well as our New Hampshire lobstermen
the questions on the report of
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1029 and this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
seconds
Shapiro
[Music]
of all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 186 in the affirmative 179 on the
adopted
the majority of the committee on fishing
game and Marine Resources to which was
referred House Bill 1100 and act
relative to coyote hunting having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Mike louette for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative alen Reed for the
minority of the committee for what
reason does a member rise make a motion
State your motion table representative
Spain moves that house bill 1100 be laid
on the table and this will be a division
seats
spe
the question is whether lay House Bill
1100 on the
table representative Spain is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill's been before us multiple
times and we've disposed of it
appropriately because fishing game sets
their own dates and seasons and if I
further know that the reason that we set
dates and seasons is to control a
population that might be in danger uh
without those dates and seasons and
coyotes are not such a animal and if I
know we have a very long day ahead of us
would I now press the green button to
bill representative Wendy Thomas has
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that house bill 1100 is a bill that
simply closes coyote hunting season
during the weeks of coyote pup raising
like we do for other animals in New
Hampshire and that you can still hunt
them outside of this season and that you
can always trap nuisance coyotes at any
time and if I know that by not hunting
coyotes during this time period you are
actually controlling the coyote
population far better than you would by
hunting them and finally if I know that
orphaned pups actually cause a greater
threat to humans due to the lack of
training from the adults in the pack
would I now press the red button to
oppose this motion so that we can all
hear the worthy and and enlightening
Speaker question is whether lay House
Bill 1100 on the table and this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
seconds
[Music]
representative
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 241 in the affirmative 123 on the
table for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion State your motion
having voting on the prevailing side I
move reconsideration of HB 1695 and urge
no representative Sweeney moves
1695 pretty sure it'll be at least a
division
vote
it
the question is whether to reconsider
the previous vote on House Bill 1695 and
this is a division vote if you are in
favor press the green button opposed
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
representative
Yella
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attended the state of the
vote 170 in the affirmative 195 in the
fails so we have one bill before lunch
and there is a debate if you stick
quicker the majority of the committee on
Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which is referred House Bill
1194 an act relative to the definition
of non-communicable disease having
considered the same report the same with
the following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative Mark
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that is an expedient to legislate
representative James Murphy for the
minority of the committee the amendment
is 0809 H printed on house record 9 on
page 54 the questions on the adoption of
the amendment you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted now the motion is ought to pass
as a amended representative Weber is
report thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1194 as written and
amended removes the word infectious from
the definition of non-communicable
diseases and as such it effectively
requires immunization only against those
diseases except for tetanus which we
just
fixed um that can
person while the amendment removing
tetanus improves the bill it still
leaves open the problem that there are
other diseases that can transfer and are
very readily transferable without
person-to-person
contact and they may require
immunization to protect the population
at large let's be clear about the
science involved in the accuracy of the
proposed definition and impact while all
communicable diseases are infectious not
all infections are
communicable for example and similar to
tetanus there are many infections and
variable vectors that can transmit
diseases that can be equally dangerous
to the public as climate change is
present Among Us other diseases may
become prevalent within our communities
and we do not want to harm our public or
handicap the future health services in
the future Co is the most recent example
demonstrating that this deadly virus can
survive on surfaces such as countertops
and door knobs and not be transmitted
personto person mosquitoes are excellent
vectors for the transmission of malaria
zika and yellow fever Legionnaire's
Disease is a deadly pneumonia
transmitted with bir bacteria and lakes
and streams and transmissible to humans
without person-to-person contct contact
germs can be transmitted on common
surfaces such as keyboards truth brush
holders cell phones and
remotes it's why we are advised to clean
services and wash our hands
regularly fortunately these diseases are
not as prevalent here in New Hampshire
as in other areas of the world today but
with the rapid Ascent of climate change
we may increasingly see non-communicable
diseases become prevalent within our
communities which may be responsive to
highly effective vaccines this bill
would narrowly Define non-communicable
and compromised future Public Health
initiatives we do not want to compromise
the health care of our communities by
handicapping our Public Health Services
with the logical and non-scientific
statutes I urge you to vote against the
motion of ought to pass as amended so
that another motion can be made and I
request a division
vote
representative Wayne McDonald's
report thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1194 removes the word
infectious from the definition of a
non-communicable disease as it relates
to the requirement for immunization and
clarifies that a non-communicable
disease is a disease that is not
transmissible from person to person the
United States and the state of New
Hampshire have always understood that
the individual has a fundamental right
to exercise sovereignty over their own
medical decisions and this understanding
is the driving force behind the patient
Bill of Rights and the requirements
around informed consent these Concepts
also carry over into the discussion
about vaccination
requirements in spite of this
understanding it is also also recognized
that an individual's medical sovereignty
is not absolute and in its Landmark 1905
decision Jacobson versus
Massachusetts the United States Supreme
Court put forth the grounds upon which
the state might override individual
sovereignty and mandate a
vaccine in Jacobson the court argued
that the state could not arbitrarily put
forth a vaccine mandate but it might
proceed if two conditions are met first
first does the Mandate have an a
substantial relation to its intended
object and second does the Mandate not
violate a fundamental
right the bipartisan majority of the
health and human services and elderly
Affairs committee felt that in the case
of diseases transmitted from person to
person both of these conditions are met
for example if a nurse and a Maternity
Ward were not vaccinated for whooping
cough it could pass to the ward like
Wildfire with potentially devastating
consequences for the infants housed
within however the majority also felt
that requiring vaccination for diseases
spread by non-human vectors Falls
outside of the standard set in Jacobson
and that the decision to pursue
vaccination in such cases should rightly
be left to the individual or the parents
of the case and of minor children being
involved the language presented in HB
1194 respects the spirit of Jacobson by
upholding the right to mandate to
preserve her immunity in the case of
personto person transmission while
defaulting to individual choice in all
other
cases concern was raised about what this
law might do to requirements around the
tetanus vaccine and as it was earli
stated the committee drafted an
amendment which we just voted on caring
out an exception to preserve the
immunization mandate for tetnus given
the great benefit and long history
history of that particular
vaccine please join the bipartisan
Committee of the Health and Human
Services Committee in supporting HB 1194
Speaker the questions on the report of
oop pass is amended on House Bill 1194
and this will be a division vote members
seats
e
the questions on the committee report
about to passes amended on House Bill
1194 representative Weber is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I recognize that there are
many diseases that are terribly terribly
infectious but that are not spread
directly personto person would I
vote no on the recommendation of octop
pass as
amended
representative McDonald's recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this legislation balances the right
of the individual with the rights of
those around them if I know that this
was voted by ought to pass as amended by
the a majority a bipartisan majority of
the committee of Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs would I
press the green button thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of a to pass is amended
this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 191 on the affirmative 171 and the
negative the report is adopted for what
reason does a member rise having voting
on the prevailing side I move
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote no representative Sweeney moves
consideration of House Bill
1194 are you ready for the question this
will be a division vote members probably
already in your
seats
yep
the question is whether to reconsider
house B
1194 if you are in favor press the green
button opposed press the red voting
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 171 in the affirmative 192 in the
fails
just so everybody knows the reason I
wasn't presiding this morning as you can
tell I woke up this morning barely able
to speak so I want to thank uh the
deputy speaker maybe a little bit later
this afternoon if I get my voice back
I'll come back but I didn't think you
wanted to sit there and listen to a
squeaky mouse like I am so uh but lunch
will be uh an hour and 15
minutes and I guess there is a free
lunch in the cafeteria area so we'll be
is and elderly Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 1213 FN an act
relative to immunization requirements
for private schools and child care
agencies having considered the same
report the same with the following
Amendment and the recommendation that
the bill ought to pass with Amendment
representative Leah kushman for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
William Palmer for the minority of the
committee representative Palmer is
recognized to speak against the report
luck a lot of loud voices that time is
over I know I'd like to get home before
8 or 9 :00 so let's just hear the
you I'm a physician who believes
prevention is the best medicine and
speak in opposition to hb1 1213
FN while the amendment that we will
better we're not
doing okay so I just need to do the Mr
dokie no no there's no debate on the
amendment right but I didn't call
it the question is on Amendment
0810 printed on house record 9 on page
61 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I all those opposed
nay eyes have it the Amendments adopted
up thank you Mr
Speaker I'm a physician who believes
prevention is the best medicine in speak
in opposition to hp1 1213 FN while the
amendment just pass makes the bill
better by continuing to require private
schools to maintain documentation of CH
children's immunization records or
exemption the bill deletes the
requirement for child care facilities
which is not in the best interest of
Public
Health the bill is opposed by the New
Hampshire Medical Society the New
Hampshire Pediatric Society the division
of Public Health Services of the
Department of Health and Human Services
the YMCA which serves thousands of
Childrens in their Early Education
programs and new
Futures among
others the YMCA wrote and I quote
immunization requirements help protect
the health and safety of of the children
and staff in our programs and reduce the
likelihood of classroom closures in the
event of an outbreak of communic
communicable
disease measles outbreaks have occurred
in multiple US states already in
2024 and polio reemerged in New York
state in
2022 despite the controversies
vaccines around vaccines vaccines remain
one of the most effective Public Health
prevention measures we don't want to go
back to 1938 when my mother who had
contracted polio at the age of 11 was
just lucky to
survive I'm also concerned that the
Department of Health and Human Services
bureau chief for reporting requirements
testified before our committee that this
bill would put New Hampshire out of
compliance with federal reporting
requirements this could jeopardize
federal child care block
grants this bill would weaken one of our
most effective Public Health protection
measures for young children and Child
Care staff would put us out of
compliance with federal reporting
requirements and would not significantly
reduce administrative burden on child
care agencies please vote against the
OTP
motion thank you Mr Speaker and I'd like
a division vote
please representative Barry's recognized
to speak for the
report thank you Mr Speaker
um with all uh due respect to my member
from the other side uh this is not a
bill about vaccines this bill does not
change the requirement to get vaccinated
141-a the reporting requirement for
child care centers which have no
business collecting this information
this is Private health information this
has nothing to do with taking a vaccine
you still have to get a vaccine or you
have to sign the religious way W these
childcare centers have the option to
hand out a religious waiver they have no
ability to determine if that religious
waiver if signed is legitimate or not it
would be grossly inappropriate for them
to do so what does happen is the
Department of Health and Human Services
issues citations for this massive
paperwork requirement bluntly speaking
the reason why my colleag from the other
side wrote from the YMCA is because the
YMCA has a staff of hundreds so it's
very easy for them to maintain this but
if you are one of the many small
businesses servicing CH children between
maybe 30 or 40 or 50 Children the
average size of a Childcare Center in
state New Hampshire this is a very
burdensome requirement so what happens
when they're out of requirement with
this what happens is they get a notice
of findings then insurance companies go
and pull that notice of findings and
they raise the rates in the child care
providers those rate costs are then
passed on to Working Families so this
bill does not stop the requirement to
get vaccinated all it does is remove a
reporting requirement that is uniquely
placed onto Child Care Centers we don't
place this burden on at home care we
only place it on Child Care Centers so
if you support getting the government
out of this unnecessary function let
Child Care Centers provide child care
and stop being reporting arms for DHHS I
bill the questions on the committee
report of octopath as
amended representative Granger requests
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the questions on the majority committee
report of ought to pass is amended on
House Bill 1213 representative Palmer is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that many New Hampshire
Healthcare organizations opposed this
bill and in fact indicated they were
worried that the rate of vaccination
would go down if this passes and if I
know the Department of Health and Human
Services testified that this bill would
put New Hampshire out of compliance with
federal reporting requirements and
jeopardize Child Care um block grants
which might lose money for the daycare
centers that are really struggling at
this point and if I know our primary
focus should be on the health and safety
of our children and not on paperwork
burden then would I now press the red
button so another motion can be made
thank you Mr
Speaker representative Barry's
recognized for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
bill does not remove the vaccination
141-a of child care and reduce a
unnecessary paperwork burden and Mr
Speaker I know that the state has other
ways to collect this information that
doesn't involve involving an entity that
is not in the business of healthcare
what I now vote green to uphold the
ought to passes amended
motion questions on the majority
committee report of aop passes amended
on House Bill 1213 and this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor press the
green button oppos press the red voting
seconds
have all members present and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 189 in the affirmative 73 and the
adopted for what reason does a member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion I'd like to move to special
order hb1 1250 to the next order of
motion you recognize speaker thank you
Mr Speaker um the uh Prime sponsor of
this bill has an urgent um need to leave
prior to 3M today and I want to make
sure that he has an opportunity to
present his bill and that we have an
opportunity to tell tell you what it's
about so I'm asking that we move it up
you the prime sponsor of the bill has an
urgent need to leave before 3 p.m. today
so I am asking that we special order
this bill to the next order of business
so that we can present our views to the
colleagues motion the motion is a
special order house Bell 1250 to the
next order of business are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose
ordered
the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
is referred House Bill 1250 an act
enabling the creation of certain Village
districts having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Laurel stavis for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Tim Cahill for the minority of the
committee representative Richard Brown
is recognized speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to the a to pass motion this
legislation would permit the creation of
Village districts for the alleged
purpose purpose of protecting lakes and
bodies of water there are many issues
that arise that make this legislation
unacceptable first these districts could
and would likely span multiple towns for
example Lake wiip pasak could
include uh excuse me could include molor
and Alton about 20 miles apart at
opposite and ends of the lake and then
all towns in between if you look at
molteno alone for instance we have both
Lake Ken ATA and lake
winaki with significantly different
issues kisaka with serious cyan cyan
bacteria issues and lake winaki with
significantly different issues which are
more General and of a wider
variety potential issues that should be
addressed specifically based on the
local
impacts are the interests of these in
Alton of those in Alton wolfboro lacone
and molteno the same I suggest no
next in the process of creating these
districts properties included in these
districts would vote to approve or
disapprove if 51% voted to approve and
49% voted
against the 49% would be subject to
assessments fees and added taxes
troubling is that fines and penalties
could be assessed to perceived offending
parties what's troubling is that this
was mentioned specifically as a positive
note when we received written
testimony now to the properties the
planners would include in the village
districts those properties would all be
lake or waterfront properties
right wrong properties could includ
those not along Waterfront as for
example elevated lands not AB budding a
water body could be claimed to have
runoff
effects so they are included in the
district or how about a property with
septic system that creators believe may
be contributing to seage into the lake
or what about a farmer's property miles
from the lakefront where's acreages
along a stream that meanders its way to
the lake can the planets of the district
save fertilizer on the farmer's land may
be leaking into the Stream So that his
land as well as the properties along the
stream are also included and everyone
here can imagine how you could have your
own scenario where property is not on
the body of water could be gerrymandered
into the
district while sponsors see The Virtue
in this bill many assert and believe
that this would become a huge
infringement on their property rights
many lakes have formed associations as a
voluntary basis to accomplish what the
bill wishes to do for instance in
molteno where I live lake kakka has an
association which is currently
addressing in a serious cyanobacteria
issue I live on molon Boro Bay on Winn
and we have the Geneva Point
Association which looks at Lake issues
and helps fund them
voluntarily the clear difference is that
this bill uses the heavy-handed the
heavy hand of bureaucracy in a mandatory
top- down all-in way those of us against
top
down all the way in those of us against
the OTP motion preferred a lighter touch
in the use of a bottomup local approach
I encourage my colleagues to join me in
opposition to
this property right anti-prop rights
legislation by pressing the red button
so that a better motion can be made
thank you Mr
Speaker representative stavis is
report thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
hb250 adds the protection and
Remediation of water surface quality to
the list of purposes for which a village
District may be
formed it has bipartisan support and if
adopted will be a much needed tool for
protecting New Hampshire's lakes and
other important bodies of
water this is bottomup legislation this
is enabling legislation only it doesn't
compel anyone to do anything instead it
allows those who live on or near Lakes
to adopt a form of municipal government
that goes back in New Hampshire law to
1957 Village districts exist to provide
services that are beyond the scope of M
municipalities ability their rules and
ordinances affect only those who live in
The District in adding these few words
to the existing law Village districts
will now be actively able to protect
their lakes and ponds New Hampshire's
Lakes are under increasing stress
seasonable and seasonal and toxic
cyanobacteria blooms have become a
regular
occurrence threatening Lakes closing
them to Recreation and even imperiling
our drinking water
supply a village District formed with
the purposes outlined in hb250 would be
able to analyze what is causing these
deadly blooms and devise ways to
remediate them such a village District
would also give members access to
research and Remediation tools not
available to them as private
citizens again nothing in hb1 1250
forces anyone to do
anything and it doesn't introduce any
radical change to existing and long
settled law it simply gives citizens a
common cause around which to gather and
provides vital tools to help our lakes
and
ponds Mr Speaker a New Hampshire without
pristine natural waterways is a New
Hampshire no one wants to Envision I
urge you to see hp1 1250 as a way to
help prevent that from happening and to
support committees ought to pass motion
Speaker a division vote's been requested
will be a division vote members take
your seats roll call Mr Speaker
representative chairart request a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded it is
vote
clear
the questions on the majority committee
report of a to pass representative Tim
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that creating
legislation that could take away
individual property rights is not the
way we do things in the Live Free or Die
state would I now press the red button
homeowners representative wolf is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker and fellow
Representatives if I know that this is
only enabling legislation and there are
14 items which are covered under the
existing Special Districts legislation
this would create a 15th one and if I
know that h B1 1250 follows a long list
of communities that have helped
themselves without burdening others who
are not affected in form Village
districts for a specific purpose and if
I know that combining the efforts of
several towns will provide a greater
opportunity for Grants outside funding
and research and if I know that this
bill is desired by many towns within the
state that wish to protect their surface
waters and if I I know that without
allowing multiple areas within various
towns to work together we are risking
the quality of our water bodies that we
hold so near and dear would I then press
the green button and pass hb1
1250 thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report about to pass on House
Bill 1250 and this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button
if you're opposed press the
red it's giving him a chance to get
back oh you're
seconds
[Music]
in
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
vote
fails kahill representative kahill moves
inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the
[Music]
question for what reason does the member
rise I move to table House Bill 1250
motion is representative Wilhelm moves
1250 this will be a division vote
seats representative chart request a
roll call that sufficiently seconded Yep
vote
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 1250 on the table and this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor press
the green button opposed press the red
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote
the house attend of the state of the
vote 182 in the affirmative 183 in the
negative tabling
fails next the question is now
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1250 are you ready for the
question imagine
that since you're all here this will be
a division vote but we do okay then well
representative turkot would like roll
call and it is sufficiently
call
all right one more time the question is
in expedient to legislate on House Bill
1250 and this is a roll call vote you
should be getting good at this by now if
you're in favor of itl press the green
button opposed press the red voting
seconds
Manion have all members present had
another opportunity to vote the house
will attend of the state of the
vote 184 in the affirmative 180 and the
negative the motion is
and hi for what reason does the member
rise we're not just not tired of voting
on 1250 yet are we having voting on the
prevailing side on hb1 1250 I move
reconsideration and urge the body to
vote
no
sure
so the the motion is reconsideration
[Music]
and and look at that a preced roll call
this will be a roll call
seats
the question is whether to reconsider
the Beloved House Bill
1250 if you are in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
shapo
[Music]
represent have all members present had
an opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
vote 179 and the affirmative 187 and the
fails for what reason does the member
that member rise uh Mr Speaker having
voting on the prevailing side of HB
12113 I move reconsideration and urge
the body to vote
no which
one
representative Sweeney moves
12113 a division's been requested this
will be a division vote members take
your
seats
the motion is whether to Recon consider
House Bill 1213 this is a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 172 in the affirmative 193 and the
fails I I recognize you cuz you're here
all the time for what reason does the
member rise yes Mr Speaker having voting
on the prevailing side on hb1
1266 I move reconsideration and urge the
now representative Sweeney moves
1266 and this will be a division
seats
e
the question is whether to Recons house
bill
of all members pres and an opportunity
to vote the house will attend to the
state of the
vote 173 in the affirmative 192 in the
fails for what reason does a member rise
Mr Speaker I have a question for the
chair okie
dokie with great respect Mr Speaker
understanding the similarity of our
names um given how late we are in the
legislative calendar understanding that
we have only several weeks more before
the
deadline and understanding how many
bills we have today to vote on is it
possible that continued requests for
[Music]
dilatory no it's it's not dilator
dilatory is successive motions of no
point on the same
thing and you're up for what reason does
a member
rise to make a motion sure I move that
we special order hb1 1416 to the next
1416 all right you can speak to your
motion thank
you uh like to to uh make this request
to special order 1416 to the next order
of business as a courtesy to the sponsor
who is scheduled to speak on it later
today but may not may have to leave
before uh we get to it this evening
this the motion was to special order
to next order of business to the next
order of business this will be a
seats
e
the question is whether to special order
House Bill 1416 to the next order of
business if this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
seconds
up
represent
O'Neal represent cyber thank
you represent
wolf representative
Smith represent
tez represent Weber I can't see her
you representative Herbert
Nomi thank
you
turot that ate up some
time have all members present had had an
opportunity to
vote the house attend of the state of
the house will attend to the state of
the
vote does he need to update goe all
right 336 in the affirmative 29 in the
negative the motion passes special order
1416 SH now for what reason does the
member rise uh I moved it indefinitely
yet you have to read the report and then
you can make the motion
first the majority of the committee on
transportation to which was referred
House Bill 1416 FN an act relative to
prohibiting parking of non-electric
vehicles and spaces designed designated
for charging electric vehicles having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is in expedient to legislate
representative John sers for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Katherine Rambo for the
committee for what reason doesn't m r to
make a motion State your motion I move
to indefinitely postpone House Bill
1416 representative Sweeney moves to
indefinitely postpone House Bill
are you ready for the
question thought so this will be a
against
the question is whether to indefinitely
postpone House Bill 1416 representative
Sweeney's recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know we only have a few weeks left
until our legislative deadlines and if I
further know that we can move on with
business today by voting yes on a
definite postponement and if I further
know
that we didn't start the fire would I
you with apologies to Billy Joel
representative Sykes is recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that we move this bill forward on an
earlier vote in recognition of respect
for our colleagues on the other side of
the aisle
as the prime sponsor who has to leave
and if I know that the indefinite prop
postponement motion is taking up way
more time than the two piis that are
scheduled for this bill would I now vote
the red button so that we can at least
hear the two pis for the bill on its
merits the question is whether to
indefinitely postpone House Bill 1416
this is a division vote if you're in
favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 189 and the affirmative 176 and the
postponed the majority of the committee
on Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which was referred house Bild
1240 an act relative to eating disorders
as a qualifying condition for the
therapeutic cannabis program having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that it
is inexpedient to legislate
representative David Nagel for the
majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Seth King
for the minority of the
committee for what reason does a m
member R um to make a motion State your
motion um Mr Speaker I'd like to table
House Bill 1240 and a division
representative Lon moves at House Bill
1240 be laid on the table are you ready
for the question she asked for a
division she asked for a division okay
it'll be a division vote members take
your
seats
okay okay yes I just didn't want you to
getou
the question is whether the L House Bill
1240 on the table and this is a division
vote representative lons recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this body has already passed House
Bill 1278 Which is far broader reaching
allowing Physicians to write a
recommendation for anybody who is an
adult and further if I know that that
bill stands a far greater chance of uh
ultimately becoming law than this bill
and lastly if I know that I was going to
make a 420 joke about 45 minutes ago uh
would I then table this bill so that we
can get to our other bills thank you
representative Kings recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that there have been a lot of people
looking forward to this bill coming to
the floor and if I believe that this
bill has a strong chance of passing and
also if I believe believe that the bills
referenced earlier haven't been signed
into law and there's still things left
to be determined would I vote no on the
tabling motion thank
you the questions whether lay House Bill
1240 on the table this is a division
vote if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 310 in
the the affirmative 54 and the negative
table
righty the majority of the committee on
Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs to which is referred House Bill
1482 an act relative to the sale of
human blood and organs having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Seth King for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill
ought to pass representative Yuri poov
for the minority of the committee for
what reason does the member rise like to
make a motion Mr Speaker State your
motion like to move to table House Bill
1482 representative Wayne McDonald moves
to lay House Bill 1482 on the table are
you ready for the
question there will be a division vote
seats who did saso requested aoll
representative Sant aaso request a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded it is not sufficiently seconded
vote
how
questions whether the L House Bill 1482
on the table representative Wayne
McDonald's recognized for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill was voted on in
the health and human services and
elderly Affairs committee overwhelmingly
by a bipartisan majority of 18 to one uh
and we voted against this bill would I
now vote uh in favor of tabling thank
you Mr
Speaker representative saso is
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know it is self it is a
self-evident truth that I possess
sovereignty over my own body and if I
know the state reporting to own my body
as a can to livestock and if I know that
legalizing organ sales will bring supply
to the market and help those whose life
depends on it and further if I know
those who receive organs would also like
the option to give the donor more than
the thank you card if I know this will
decrease Hospital occupancy and costs
freeing up care for
all if I know this will reduce black
market
activity and if I know that people want
to want to be good people and help
others but sometimes they need a little
cash to grease the wheels then when I
press the red button so we can uh
Speaker the questions with the L House
Bill 1482 on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the
seconds
represent
bre
B members present had an opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 326 in the affirmative 38 in the
table
the committee on Health Human Services
and elderly Affairs to which was
referred House Bill 1660 FN relative to
coverage of certain procedures for minor
children under the state's Medicaid
Program comes to us without
recommendation representative kofalt
pass representative Weber is recognized
to speak against the
motion
thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill
1660 extends far beyond the prohibitions
that we already voted on earlier this
year that was a Prohibition on gender re
gen genital gender reassignment
surgery this bill would prohibit
Medicaid from paying for any kind of
gender reassignment surgery so that
means breast surgery as well as genital
surgery now we are all
agreed that for the most part it is best
to wait until 18 before these decisions
are
taken
however in some
cases it is absolutely lifesaving
surgery and if agreed to by the
individual the individual's parent or
Guardian the various Health Care
Providers it's a real necessity for the
individual that needs it and families
should be left to make those
decisions and if we prohibit Medicaid
for paying for this
surgery we are
creating a
discrimination against those who are
poor we're creating two different kinds
of Medical Practice one for those with
resources and one for those
without and
secondly we are creating a
discriminatory
category because we are labeling one
particular group of people as being
Unworthy of medical
treatment the concern that I have is
that this bill is part of what is an
emerging
fabric of
attacks on people who are
lgbtq plus and I don't think we ought to
be going down that road I don't think we
ought to be creating two tiers of
medical practice and I think we ought to
be pressing the red button on ought to
pass so a better motion can be made
thank
you representative kofos recognize speak
Speaker in early January this house took
the
position that children should not be
undergoing permanent irreversible
surgery in New Hampshire
that they may very well
regret this bill is extraordinarily
simple it states that the New Hampshire
Medicaid Program will not cover gender
children to those who would say this
creates some kind of two-tier Health
Care System there are numerous private
healthcare plans that do not cover these
adults the opposing committee report
discriminatory this bill merely
asserts that taxpayers should not be on
the hook to pay for gender reassignment
minors not only is that taking money
scarce public resource versus out of
public
coffers it is also potentially creating
a liability for the State of New
Hampshire because there are huge issues
uh huge questions remaining around
liability when someone comes back later
and
says I was young I didn't know what I
was
doing and I was talked into this or not
adequately
screened the the opposing committee
reports ass asserts that this is
discriminatory I would assert that there
are a number of things that we do not
allow children to do in the state of New
Hampshire including drinking alcohol
smoking cigarettes in fact in the state
of New Hampshire we do not allow
children anyone under the 18 under the
salon in light of that it does not sound
discriminatory it's sounds like common
sense that we do not want to use
taxpayer funds to fund gender
reassignment surgery that is
irreversible and highly likely to cause
later
regrets Mr Speaker I urge my
colleagues to vote in favor of the OTP
motion and I ask for a roll call vote
Speaker for what reason does the member
rise to make a motion State your motion
I wish to table uh HB
1660 representative Murray r that house
bill 1660 be laid on the table today
somebody ask for a roll
call repres Jan request a roll call it
is sufficiently seconded this will be a
seats
wor
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 1660 on the table representative
Murray's recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that we already have a long
day ahead of us and we don't need to go
back and forth on controversial bills
and if I also note that the lgbtq Youth
of New Hampshire have already faced so
much harassment from this body that we
do not need to add on to the fear that
they're feeling right now and Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill sets up a
two-tiered system within our public
healthare deciding who and who does not
receive that Health Care would I now
press the green button to table this
bill
so representative kof fall recognized
for parliamentary inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that the majority of New Hampshire
residents do not support the idea of
irreversible gender reassignment surgery
for minors and that they don't want to
pay it for their with their tax dollars
or incur future liabilities for the
State of New Hampshire would I then
press the green button
to I'm sorry my apologies uh would I
then press the red button so that we
could move forward with uh with the
motion that was on the floor thank
you the question is whether the L House
Bill 1660 on the table and this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent
to all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 174 in the affirmative 188 in the
negative the motion
fails now the question is are to pass on
House Bill
1660 representative Granger request a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
oh
C question before the house is
the motion of about to pass on House
Bill
1660 representative Weber is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that the vast majority
of the citizens of New Hampshire want
parents families to make decisions with
their minor children in consultation
with medical providers and other
counselors of that family's
choosing and if I know that I do not
want to deny appropriate Medical Care to
one specific category of people would I
now press the red button so a better
motion can be
made representative kof Falls recognized
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the uh majority of the
residents of New Hampshire still do not
believe that their tax dollars should
pay for um irreversible surgeries for
minors that they may soon
regret would I this time press the green
button so that this ought to pass motion
succeed EDS thank you Mr Speaker the
questions on the motion about to pass on
House Bill 1660 this is a roll call vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
seconds
represent
Ms all members present and an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the vote
193 and the affirmative 169 and negative
adopted for what reason does the member
rise having voting on the prevailing
side I move reconsideration on House
Bill 1660 and urge the body to vote no
representative Sweeney moves
reconsideration on House Bill 1660 are
you ready for the
question Yep this will be a division
vote members take your
seats
e
the question is whether to reconsider
House Bill 1660 there is a division vote
if you're in favor press the green
button oppose press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 171 in
the affirmative 192 in the negative
reconsideration
[Music]
fails
for what reason does the member rise I'd
like to indefinitely postpone 1706
that yeah okay the majority of the
committee on Health Human Services and
elderly Affairs s refer to House Bill
1706 FN an act relative to not notice
required to uh prior to circumcision
procedure having considered the same
report the same with the recommendation
that the bill be referred for interim
study representative Leah kushman for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
following resolution resolved it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
David Nagel for the minority of the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of inim study are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
adopted committee on Judiciary to which
was referred
cac12 an act relating to the definition
of the word cherish providing that the
1784 word cherish shall be replaced by
the 2024 word cherish having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
margerie Smith for the
committee representative Dan Maguire is
recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr
Speaker cacr 12 is a constitutional
amendment designed to correct the
erroneous New Hampshire Supreme Court 19
N 1993 Claremont
decision that decision said that this
phrase in part two of article three of
art part two article 83 of the
Constitution which reads in part it
shall be the duty of legislators to
cherish the interest of literature The
Sciences and all seminaries and public
schools um that they ruled that that
requires us to allocate funds from
Statewide sources to pay for an adequate
education for all
students cacr 12 is designed to nudge
the Supreme Court to a correct
interpretation of that part of the
Constitution so first of all I want to
dispel the notion that the constitution
is something that could only be
understood by experts and judges and the
Supreme Court and so on the Constitution
was created in uh
1784 um it was the draft was made by a
committee who took the Constitution from
Massachusetts made some modifications
and sent it out to all of the towns
where the people read it they met in
their um annual
meeting and voted on it and they voted
it
down and they sent suggestions back to
uh the committee the committee over the
next period made
changes um sent new copies out to the
towns all the people read it they
discussed it they voted on it and they
turned it
down so same process the people sent
more suggestions to the
committee uh the committee made changes
they they reiterated they sent new
copies of the towns they discussed it
and the third time was the charm so our
constitution was read by Ordinary People
was voted on by Ordinary People it it
does not contain weird obscure language
that that only only judges can
understand the second notion that's in
the Claremont decision is that the word
ch Parish itself had sort of an obscure
18th century meaning that is different
than our our meaning today right because
today we would just think okay we're
going to encourage or like or support or
something like that but but that the
meaning was specifically you know must
pay
for and that is not true either so my
Authority for this is the gentleman
standing behind me
here
and I don't mean our Clerk or you Mr
Speaker I mean George
Washington okay so George Washington
served as president for eight years and
his most famous speech is his farewell
address in
1796 and in that Farewell Address he
happened to use the word cherish three
times and I would submit to you he used
it exactly as we would today he said
that we should cherish our National
union he said that we should cherish
religion and
morality and he said that we should
cherish the Public
Credit right so we shouldn't borrow too
much money unfortunately we haven't
listened to him but you know all right
so the Supreme Court made a big deal of
of looking up the word cherish in a 1784
dictionary and they found it to say to
support to shelter to nurse up
well you could maybe think of nursing up
that might include some paying for right
but the problem is the the next line in
the dictionary defines
cherisher as an
encourager or a
supporter right so now we're thinking
about people who like the Patriots or
something like that right and um and the
following word was
similar um cherishment means
encouragement support Comfort it doesn't
really mean pay for okay and then then
their further step of saying how much we
had to pay that we had to fully pay
that's just glossed over in the
Claremont
decision okay and then the obvious
question is if we interpret cherish
literature Sciences all seminaries and
public schools as meaning send a defined
amount of money to schools the obvious
question
is where are the checks for authors and
scientists and
seminaries right that's somehow ignored
by the Supreme
Court and then
finally um there's the original part one
article six of this of the Constitution
that had was in it at the same time as
this phrase and that one says that the
people empowered the legislature to
authorize the several towns to make
adequate provision at their own
expense for the support and maintenance
of public Protestant
teachers okay so we are authorized at at
that time we were authorized to to have
towns um give money at at their own
expense and to to further that was the
fact that for the first 50 years that
the constitution was in effect the
legislature sent zero to towns for
schools all right so now that we know
that the Claremont decision was
incorrect why should we do anything
about it now right we've we've lived
with it for 30 years we are certainly
going to keep supporting schools right
so what's what's the the
urgency the question is not just not not
whether we're going to support schools
but how and how
much that's ultimately a legislative
decision not a Judicial
one over the years this the state has
supported schools by filling in the gaps
that occur uh between poorer and
wealthier
communities that's why a city like
Berlin gets
$111,000 a kid and a city like and a
nothing all right so these are
inherently political decisions which
should be left up to the
425 elected officials in this body as
well as the go the one across the hall
and the
governor and not unelected and
unaccountable
judges
now last year there was a court case
called conal and the judge in the conal
case told the state that we must spend a
lot more money on education in
particular uh roughly 500 million doll
more that we must the state must send
that that amount of money more to to the
public
schools now we can do that actually it's
it's not that difficult we could put in
150% increase in the Statewide education
property tax all right what that would
do is shift money around just like we do
every year in the budget when we make
changes to the adequate education
formula we move money around and we
create winners and we create
losers doing
this um will among the winners be
suburbs that have a lot of kids
wealthier suburbs that have a lot of
kids such as Bedford and boow for
example those are the kind of towns
that'll be winners under the Supreme
Court's convel
decision and one other group that will
be winners that might surprise
you is charter schools and
efas under the Supreme Court's
formula um actually not the Supreme
Court yet right this is a lower level
judge but under the the conval formula
charter schools and efas will get an
extra
$3,200 a kit right so efas will go up by
50% and Charter Schools less than
that but I'm sure that not everyone in
this body would like that
outcome so please let's overturn this
itl mod motion and vote for bringing
back these kind of decisions into the
legislature where they belong thank you
Mr
Speaker representative margorie Smith is
report thank you Mr
Speaker the distinguished gentleman from
Epson made an a speech that I do not
disagree with at all he talked about his
concerns about several decisions made by
the judicial branch that he believes uh
do not reflect certainly his values and
those values and those of other people
who share those values and that is a
legitimate
respectable position
in fact the amendment
however is perhaps a little too clever
by half the amendment changes nothing to
say cherish should be supplanted by
Cherish does not inform this legislature
or inform the public that would have to
vote on this that what the spons
envisioned is that therefore the
legislature would no longer have to deal
with court involvement in deciding how
much the state should pay for Education
if in
fact the Judiciary Committee had before
it an amendment which
said let's get the courts out of their
long-term responsibilities under the con
institution and leave education strictly
to the legislative branch some people
would support that some people would not
but they would know what the issue is to
substitute the word cherish according to
a
1784 dictionary for the 2024 Miriam
Webster does not make that issue clear
and for all of us who respect the
Constitution and take it
seriously if we want to make a change we
ought to be clear what that change is
and therefore on behalf of 16 members of
the Judiciary Committee um I hope that
you will support our position to itl
this Constitutional Amendment and in the
fullness of time we will again and again
and again revisit how we fund education
but we will do it by saying what we're
really doing thank you very much Mr
Speaker the questions on the motion the
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate representative Dan Maguire
requests a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the questions the majority committee
report of in expedient to legislate on
cacr
12 representative Ammon is recognized
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that
cac12 seeks to amend a Judicial
misinterpretation regarding education
funding to better align with the
framer's actual intent and if I know the
critical role of the term cherish in our
foundational documents and its
problematic interpretation in the 1990s
Claremont decision in which the state
supreme court legislated from the bench
and used this word to justify a
departure from two centuries old
practice of Educational Funding and if I
know that the necessity of re re
reinstating this legislature's authority
to make sane budgetary decisions that we
need to correct this error to avoid
fiscal policies that would require
potentially new broad-based
taxes and if I know that passing this
amendment would allow this body and the
citizenry at large to inform the
judicial branch about the correct
interpretation of the word cherish would
I now press the red button to defeat the
itail motion so that a better motion
could be made thank
you representative divines recognized
inquiry
Mr Speaker if I understand correctly the
proposed cacr
12 which seeks to replace the 1784 word
cherish with the
2024w cherish in article 83 of the New
Hampshire
Constitution when there's nothing wrong
with the word cherish
doesn't that raise a red flag that
undermines the word cherishes meaning if
I know that quibbling over semantics
although may seem
trivial but altering the language of the
constitution in such
a cutesy manner diminishes The
Constitution's
significance and if I know the
difference
between words like cherish as used in
article 83 implies a solemn Duty and
obligation of the state government to
support public education whereas the
word encouraged is used in article 83
suggests a less binding commitment to
private
institutions and if I know this SE
semantic shift could have far-reaching
implications for the state's
responsibility towards funding public
education and the principles upheld by
long-standing legal precedents such as
the Claremont
ruling and then
furthermore if if I know that this could
potentially open the floodgates of other
cacr amendments to be used as a tool to
alter language of in the in the
Constitution and lastly if I know cac12
does not uphold the Integrity of the
democratic process or protect the
principles enshrined in the New
Hampshire
Constitution and at its root it seems
like some full sugar honey iced tea then
would I press the green button to itl
this bill so that we the people in New
Hampshire are not burdened with voting
on this matter and oh Mr Speaker standon
if I may encourage you to push the green
preserve and cherish I I would really
appreciate your vote and I'd cherish
it
I'm going to start counting if I knows
from now
on question is the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
cacr 12 this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
opposed press the red voting stations
seconds
[Music]
represent
Hicks
mses have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 188 in the affir 177 and negative
adopted I'll dry my best while Steve
the committee on Judiciary to which R
refer at House Bill 1037 relative to
repealing limited liability for
manufacturers Distributors dealers or
Imports of firearms or
moves inter stud interim study okay maor
Smith moves representative Smith moves
interim study what reason does the
memorize to make a motion State your Mo
State your motion I move indefinitely
1037 representative hul is requested a
roll calls that sufficiently seconded it
is sufficiently seconded this will be
a this will be a roll call vote members
seats
he goes first
the motion before us on HP 1037 is
indefinite
postponement this is going to be a roll
call vote chair recognizes
representative Alexander for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know we have a lot to get through
today and I know this is an anti-second
amendment Bill and would completely um
destroy this the uh gun Manufacturing in
the state would I then press the green
button thank
you J recognizes representative Moder
Smith for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if you know
that this is an issue that is of
incredible importance to the New
Hampshire legislature that has focused
always on the rights of gun
manufacturers and recognizing how
important so many members of the body
believe that to be um if you want to
make make sure that serious
consideration is given to these issues
so that we can have a position that is
acceptable to everybody would you vote
no on indefinite postponement so that
the committee in uh could we could
discuss this bill and if you support the
committee um the committee would then
work on on interim study to try to
the motion before us on House Bill 1037
is indefinite postponement this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button boning
seconds
[Music]
I'll try getting closer to them m
mhone um have all members present at the
opportunity to
vote 196 voting yay 180 163 voting nay
passes the committee on to Judiciary to
which was referred House Bill 1089 now
relative to statute of limitations on
civil actions involving past considered
the same report the same with a
recommendation that the bill be referred
for interim study s marjerie Smith for
the
committee are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppos nay
passes
can't
very
majority of the committee on on
Judiciary to which was referred House
Bill 1220 FN act relative to abolishing
the collection of racial and ancestrial
data for use in marital application
worksheet considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
recommendation the bill ought to pass
with Amendment presentative Ben Bing for
the majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered this aim and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolve
that is inexpedient to legislate s of
committee the committee amendment is
0415 H printed in house record 9 page 61
the motion is on the committee Amendment
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I I I oppose nay you eyes
have it and the committee amendment is
adopted the bills on second reading open
to further Amendment Senator Perez
office floor Amendment
07938 printed in house record 9 Pages 61
62 and recognized to speak to her
Amendment thank you Mr Speaker first of
all the marriage application does not
require this information the only app
information that the marriage applic a
requires is your name your resident your
date of birth your social security
number your mother's maen name your
father's madeen name it doesn't require
any of these things the
amendment which eliminates this
eliminates ancestry it moves our
personal history the origin of your
family the line of your descent it
prevents future generations to view
their
history names may change but your
lineage does not future Generations
might also want to obtain this
information because it might be valuable
in the future for perhaps medical
information or medical studies that come
down the line now my name is Christine
Perez would you ever think that I am
first generation
the
mo the motion before us is the parez is
the parez
[Music]
floor so we've had a request for
division there has been request for
division on the amendment members take
your
seats
is
yes
l
can I do a pi
yes
so
tile
[Music]
representative
voting members should be in their
on
we're we're in the voting mode let's
find our
seats represent Weber representa ly
V representative margerie Smith do you
have a parliamentary inquiry thank you
very much Mr Speaker and I would like to
begin my parliamentary inquiry first by
um announcing how pleased I am that
you're there rather than um the speaker
whose voice should not be strained so
know you're absolutely right thank you
very much I'm glad for that advice if I
know as I do that the body of this
amendment is exactly the same as the
body of the amendment that you just
voted
on and the only difference between the
two um amendments is a change in the
statement of purpose the title of the
amendment would you then
join the um a majority of the Judiciary
Committee that supported the First
Amendment
you representative Perez is recognized
for parliamentary inquiry if I know in
your calendar the bill the amendment was
misrepresented and it said that my
Amendment crossed out the word ancestry
and I I know that that was
a mistake done in the calendar and if I
know my bill my amendment allows for
ancestry to be kept on the um
information that you may fill out on
vote green push the green button for to
amendment all right
then the question is whether to adopt
floor Amendment
H if you're in favor press the green
button oppos press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
represent
bber
have all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 3 24 in the affirmative 33 and the
negative the Amendments
adopted Point
clarification point of clarification the
chair recognizes the clerk thank you Mr
Speaker just to correct
uh the uh understanding the amendment as
printed on page 61 and 62 of your house
calendar is exactly as drafted by the
office of legislative services and does
strike out their race and ancestry and
level of education so uh the amendment
that you just voted does do the same
Amendment am she's going to speak
against
any
and now we're on to the main motion of a
to pass as amended representative Perez
is recognized speak against the
committee
Perez thank you Mr Mr Speaker there is
no reason to remove this information
from the application it is not required
information it is voluntary
information so why remove it why have to
pay to change all the applications that
come out in the future leave it the way
it is and let people who want to
research their
ancestry in the future the ability to do
that thank you
vote no I would push the red button on a
to pass representative Ms recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker the state of
New Hampshire currently asks for race
and ancestry data on its marriage
applications any here we go how's this
all right
okay any couple going to their local
clerk's office is asked to provide this
information as part of the process for
receiving a marriage
license although the paperwork
connecting a person to their race is
ultimately destroyed after the data is
collected and the marriage license is
issued there's still a significant
problem hb1 1220 would remove this
unconstitutional
requirement the governor singled out
this very Issue four years ago in a
letter to the house speaker and the
president of the other body urging them
to find a legislative solution to the
for this issue out of a more expansive
Bill the interest that the Attorney
General's office had in now revisiting
this idea came about because it not only
believes this is still a problem to be
addressed in New Hampshire it is also
aware of successful efforts to remove
similar data collection requirements in
other state
courts the primary reason to Halt this
practice above all else is to protect
access to
marriage marriage is not simply an
institution of belief it is a
fundamental
right those cases in other states W on
the argument that the requirement to
provide race and ancestry data would
marrying more specifically it was
determined to be a restriction of a
fundamental right with the law worthy of
being assessed under the standard of
strict scrutiny the highest level of
constitutional review by our court
system the only way a law is allowed to
impede the right to
marry is the identification of a
compelling governmental interest and the
state of New Hampshire doesn't have one
the Attorney General's office has worked
with the division of Vital Records who
shared that this data is not used for
any reason other than to just retain it
and it's mostly duplicative of US Census
Data I encourage you to vote green on
the motion of ought to pass as amended
because a vote in favor of
hb220 is a vote to correct the
unconstitutional collection of race and
ancestry data and to protect the
fundamental right of marriage thank you
vote the question is on the committee
report about to pass as as amended this
[Music]
seats
w
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass as amended
representative Christine Perez is
inquiry she she's waving off would you
like
to you going to go
anyway representative margerie Smith
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr speaker if um I
know that this legislation was uh
requested by the Attorney General's
office um in order to have New Hampshire
conform with um federal federal law and
that it this legislation helps to
support this legislature's strong belief
in the importance of marriage and family
would you now join the overwhelming
majority of the Judiciary Committee by
voting otpa thank
you the questions the majority committee
report about to pass as amended on House
Bill 1220 this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
e
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 2 93 in the affirmative 64 and the
adopted
the committee on Judiciary to wish
referred House Bill 1412 FN relative to
court reporters sends it to us without
recommendation representative Lynn moves
a to pass the floor Amendment
pocketses there he is representative Lyn
is recognized to speak to his
motion colleagues U on this motion the
uh the amendment the only thing that it
does is change the effective date of
this bill if it passes from 60 days to
90 days this was a request made after
the hearing by one of the court reporter
representatives and I told the court
reporter representative that I would
draft such an amendment by the at the
for the to be to be uh for our executive
session and I did have it drafted and we
were so busy at the executive session
that frankly I forgot to offer the
amendment um I really felt badly about
that because I made a commitment to this
person I would do it it's a perfectly
reasonable request if the bill passes so
I hope I know we're going to have a
debate on the bill itself but I hope
everyone will be able to agree that this
amendment is entirely appropriate and I
urge you to vote in favor of the
amendment the questions on the adoption
of amendment 0901 H are you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose nay the eyes have it
and the Amendments adopted now the
question is the main motion of ought to
pass as amended representative margerie
motion Mr Speaker this is not the first
time we have seen this language the
language was initially proposed in House
Bill 2 last year when there was um a
determined effort to uh cut down
dramatically um the licensing and
regulation uh of many many um entities
in the state it was was pulled out of
hb2 and it's now here as part of an
effort on a caseby Case basis to De
deregulate uh
licensing and so you have to understand
this is not a new issue but it's a very
important issue I was privileged to be
named by the speaker to serve on a
special committee on the family
court and we were worked very hard over
the last year or so looking at what was
happening in the Family Court listening
to people who had some concerns and
trying to evaluate those
concerns one part of that
review that I must say gave me
absolutely no pleasure was to read
transcripts that had been prepared in
the Family Court trans that were full of
Errors omissions
confusion that not only meant that there
record as you know my mother taught me
never to speak when others were speaking
close it was not only uh I an injustice
perhaps for those people who were in the
courts but for those of us who are
charged with evaluating what goes on in
those courts those transcripts were not
written by court reporters because
several years ago the courts generally
acted to remove court reporters and
instead to use um recording devices
which someone or other was responsible
for turning on at the start and one
hopes turning off at the end of a court
day sometimes that works sometimes that
doesn't but that's the Court's problem
the court has to make those decisions
for themselves however court reporters
have a lot of other
responsibilities and they are trained
they are uh evaluated they are
licensed um they have continuing
education
requirements they um take depositions
for legal proceedings they do all kinds
of things that determine in fact at the
end the quality of the judicial
process um and it is because of that
that the committee um uh that half of
the committee it was 1010 believe that
in fact court reporters do continue to
provide uh an important function with
high
standards and uh and it was something
that we ought to protect not for
particularly for our benefit but for the
benefit of the citizens who are in
situations that involve the need for an
accurate record of what is going on
therefore we would ask that you um
vote uh
against uh uh the bill which would mean
supporting the itl motion that was
supported by 10 of the committee members
um and hope you will do that in the best
interest of the quality of the work we
need from people who carry out this
essential function thank
you representative Linds recognized to
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker when this bill was
first in committee our speaker ameritus
from conquer a person who I have known
and greatly respected for more than 40
years testified against the bill he
related the great respect he had for
court reporters based on his observe his
experience observing them in court when
he was with the United States Marshal's
office
and he said ending State regulation of
them would threaten the accuracy and
integrity of Cru of crucially important
court
records 20 years ago I could not have
agreed more strongly with the views he
expressed at that time the Superior
Court where I was a judge exclusively
used court reporters to make the
verbatim stenographic records of Trials
and hearings but at about that time
time as a moneysaving move the Supreme
Court decided to terminate the court
reporters and replace them with a tape
recording system that would record all
proceedings and would be operated by a
by a much lower paid person called a
monitor whose job would be to make sure
that recording devices were working
properly and to collect and marked
exhibits Etc most of us judges on the
superior court at this time my self
included were strongly opposed to
terminating the court reporters because
just like the speaker ameritus We
Believe doing so would be a disaster in
terms of the accuracy and integrity of
the record of Court proceedings and
candidly beyond our professional
concerns we trial judges had great
affection for our court reporters they
were part of our court family and we
didn't want to see them
terminated the whole thing got very very
ugly the court reporters unionized they
filed a lawsuit trying to prevent their
discharge the case went to the Supreme
Court where most of the judges recused
themselves and a number of retired
Superior Court judges were substituted
in their place and eventually in a 3 to2
decision the court upheld the
termination of the court
reporters but as it turned out I was
wrong
over the past 20 years the tape
recording system implemented by the
Supreme Court has worked just fine have
there been a few problems occasionally
from time to time yes but there were a
few problems with the court
reporters and it did save the the state
a great deal of money the recording
devices work well and when a transcript
is needed the court system uses an
outfit in Arizona to which the record
boings have been sent for years to uh
prepare the the written transcripts the
point of all this is that although they
are still called court reporters they
could more accurately be called
non-court reporters because they no
longer are used in the state court
system their work today consists mostly
of making a stenographic record of of
depositions and other outof court
proceedings where a Verbatim record is
needed the arguments offered now for why
court reporters should be regulated by
the state the need to ensure accuracy
and integrity of the testimonial record
are exactly the same arguments that were
made 20 years ago for not terminating
their positions in the
court those arguments were turned out to
be wrong then and they are wrong now
State regulation of court reporters is
unnecessary in the 17 years that the
court licensing system has been in
effect there has never been an
enforcement or disciplinary proceeding
involving a court reporter the current
scheme requires court reporters to be
licensed which in turn requires that
they hold certification from one of the
two national cred credentialing bodies
and that they comply with a code of
ethics and continuing education
requirement issued by these bodies
lenses must be renewed every two uh
every licenses must be renewed every two
years and court reporters also must be
bonded in the amount of
$1,000 all of these requirements have
costs and fees associated with them
please understand as proponents of
deregulation we do not suggest that
credentialing by the national
associations or continuing education or
bonding are bad things we simply say
that there is no reason for the state to
be involved in any of this the people
who use cour court reporters are a
sophisticated group they are mostly
attorneys or other professionals if they
want a court reporter who has the
national credential or the continuing
education or the bonding they can make
any or all of these things uh conditions
of hiring the court reporter for a
particular job in short this is
something that the marketplace can
handle the only real effect of Licensing
is to limit competition in this field
under the law no one can engage in
stenographic or a similar type of court
reporting without a license to do so is
a crime the license is timec consuming
and relatively expensive to obtain
moreover although the need for a license
technically does not apply to someone
who may desire to use a tape recorder to
make and preserve the record the
statutory prohibition against using
these terms quote court reporter Court
recorder verbatim reporter verbatim
court reporter or verbatim Court Rec uh
recorder make it very difficult for
someone Desiring to use this method to
advertise the availability of their
services in a meaningful way to those
who might be interested in the uh in
marketing
them there are not me there are not a
great many licensed court reporters and
the cost of this regulatory scheme in
the overall Universe of State regulation
is relatively
small but the principle at stake here is
an important one the question you must
decide by your vote is this does this
legislative body have the red have the
will to reduce the size of government
just a little bit to take a baby step to
reduce the state's regulatory footprint
and enhance economic freedom in an area
where Public Safety and Health are not
at all implicated I submit to you
respectfully colleagues that if we can't
dis deregulate this industry it's hard
to imagine how we will ever be able to
deregulate any industry for these
reasons I urge you to press the green
button and Mr Speaker I respectfully
you the questions on the motion of ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 1412
this will be a division vote members
seats representative Sweeney has
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
vote
I
e
seats
the question is on the motion to V to
pass as amended on House Bill 1412 and
this is a roll call
vote representative Gro is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr speak Mr
Speaker if I know that the institute for
justice a public interest legal firm
testified between before Edna and said
that New Hampshire had a light touch on
licensing a light touch and if I know
that court reporters are more dependable
than
technology and also lastly if I know
that court reporters act in many
environments including but not limited
to depositions and other legal
proceedings excuse me would I not press
the green button but no would I not
press the red button so it's been one of
those days I have would I not please
press the red button and defeat this
motion so that another motion can be
made thank
you representative Tony leakas is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that court reporters are no longer used
in the New Hampshire courts and if I
know that the professionals that hire
them for out of court proceedings can
impose similar requirements when hiring
them as licensing currently does if they
wish or use other methods uh to record
proceedings and if I know that this
license does nothing to protect the
health and safety of the public which is
the legitimate purpose of Occupational
licensing would I then press the green
button to support the OTP Mo otpa motion
to eliminate this burdensome and outm
moded license thank you Mr
Speaker questions on the motion of V to
pass as amended on now Bill 1412 and
this is a roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button oppos press
seconds
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 188 in the affirmative 166 and the
adopted before we move on
somebody pointed something out to me
that was a really good point when you
move for there to be a roll call and
then I asked if it's sufficiently
seconded you should not stand up because
you should not second your own motion
that the committee on legislative
Administration to which is referred as
Bill 1629 FN relative to attorney
general's duties concerning legislators
residing in different districts than
they represent comes to us without
recommendation for what reason does the
member rise for a motion Mr Speaker
please State your motion Mr Speaker I
move that we lay House Bill 1629 on the
table representative we and I request a
division vote I'm sorry and I request a
division vote okay representative Weber
moves that we lay House Bill 1629 on the
table this will be a division vote
seats
[Music]
you
the motion is whether to lay House Bill
6 1629 on the table representative
Weber's recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that house bill
1629 was filed to establish a
transparent notification process
regarding the residency violation
of
legislators and if I Now understand that
the attorney general has notified the
speaker and the minority leader to
inform them that the Department of
Justice has established a new protocol
to ensure investigatory information
regarding the residency of sitting
legislators is shared with both parties
would I now press the green button to
support the motion to lay House Bill
1629 on the table thank you Mr
Speaker the question is whether the lay
House Bill 6 29 on the table this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppose press the red
seconds
representative
saso of all members present had an
opportunity to
vote the house will attend to the state
of the
vote 339 in affirmative 19 and the
table the majority of the committee on
legislative Administration to which was
referred
hr29 an act declaring an economic
Justice Bill of Rights having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate Representative
Steven Pearson for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for inm study represent of
Janet wal from the minority of the
committee the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppose
adopted the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred House Bill 1086 an act
relative to public notice of zoning
Board of adjustment hearings having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Diane power from the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass
representative Jim maiori from the
minority of the committee the questions
on the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppose
adopted the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred House Bill 1120 an act
repealing the provision that requires
the reflection of Municipal body votes
on warrant articles having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Richard Brown for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having of the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Josh toell from the
minority of the committee representative
Dunn is recognized to speak against the
committee
report thank you Mr Speaker good
afternoon fellow Representatives on
March 12th it's to meeting day for most
of us in this chamber this is where we
go to the polls and we vote on Warren
articles these warrant articles are
currently by state law are mandated to
have the budget committee the Town
Council or the select boards vote on
those ballots it's required to be
printed on there if this vote if we
decide to overturn this itl and make
another motion all this bill would do is
remove the RSA that says that these
these uh votes are not printed on the
ballot printing the votes on the ballot
is election airing this bill would
remove the votes from being printed on
the ballot this bill does not remove the
ability of the municipal bodies to vote
on the warrant articles it would only
remove the votes from being printed on
the ballots Municipal bodies can still
vote on the warrant articles the public
will still know the opinions of the
municipal bodies but they will not be
printed on the ballot this bill will
stop electioneering in the ballot
Booth I am not allowed to walk in to the
ballot location with a hat a pin a
sticker or a sign that says vote Yes on
three however my vote as a town
counselor is on that ballot and I submit
to you that my vote has more power on
that ballot than any hat sticker pin or
sign you'd walk into the ballot Booth
with voter X walks into the ballot Booth
they get their ballot they go into the
ballot Booth they don't know what
warrant article 3 is about but they see
the very last thing they read oh my
counselor Ron Dunn he voted for this I'm
going to vote for it how's that any
different than me standing right next to
voter X saying vote for this it's
election earing I'm I'm there in the
ballot Booth with them that my vote is
on that
ballot my vote is the last thing the
voter is going to read this being
printed on the ballot has more influence
over the voter than anything we
currently classify as election
hearing I ask you vote no on the itail
so another motion can be made Mr Speaker
I ask for a division vote thank you
representative Richard Browns recognized
report thank you Mr Speaker thank you
fellow Representatives many voters who
attend Town meetings do not have the
ability to attend governing body
meetings or the time to review those
meetings online but do want to know how
their members voted after all they voted
for them to be the community to do the
community work and want to know how they
voted on important issues in many cases
I feel the officials have expertise and
time to investigate these matters that
they can't and in most instances people
trust them but also want to confirm that
their officials are accountable to
them when the members vote tally is
shown along with the warrant articles
people can see several things for
instance if it's a 4 to zero vote it
could give voters confidence in the
article's validity if it's a split vote
2 two for instance it would likely bring
people to question it if it's 0 to four
it would likely be a serious consider
consideration for them to examine and in
any case it gives people additional
information a more informed vote from my
experience it also typically prompts
questions from
voters who voted which way and why is
what they want to know in the house we
have a majority and minority reports we
also have white sheets gold sheets pink
sheets and whatever information people
hand to us as we enter the house I
always look at the majority and minority
reports and look at how the vote is
split I always look at this to help
determine how hard I should look at an
issue in all cases I want to know how
the committee voted what the numbers
were I can't possibly attend all the
hearings in the house just as residents
can't or don't have the time to attend
or view all the meetings that they would
like
to not showing the governing Bonnie vote
count limits voter information for no
good reason it may imply that since the
article is presented everyone supports
it
we want informed voters please support
itl and don't remove information that
many voters use to make good decisions
vote green to itl this unnecessary
you the question is on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose nay
no
adopted he asked for a division during
his speech so we're going to do a
division vote no no no ask because
because you you stated the vote yeah
reconsideration I'm used to it so a pro
having voting on the prevailing side I
would move reconsideration on HB 1120
and I would urge the body to vote
Yes Voice
vote the question is whether to
reconsider the previous vote on House
Bill 1120 are you ready for the question
really okay I guess this will be a
I
he
questions whether to reconsider the
previous vote on House Bill 1120
representative sween's recognized for
parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I Mr Speaker if I know the
member had previously asked for a
division vote on this bill and Mr
Speaker if I know that that was was was
not heard uh but further Mr Speaker if I
know that we've been very accommodating
today on various motions to have votes
on bills uh other times would I now vote
Yes for reconsideration so that the
underlying motion can be voted on again
via a division vote thank
you the question is whether to
reconsider house bill 1120 the this is a
division vote if you're in favor press
the green button oppos press the red
seconds
[Music]
representative
Aaron of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote
188 in the affirmative 168 in the
negative reconsideration passes now back
to itl we are now back to inexpedient to
legislate and this will also be a
division
vote representative cordelli request a
roll call is that sufficiently seconded
it is sufficiently seconded this will be
seats
e
the question is the motion of been
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1120 representative Christine Perez is
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if I
know that printing the vote of the
municipal body on the ballot is
electioneering and Mr Speaker if I know
that this is the last thing voters read
before casting their vote and Mr Speaker
if I know that the vote of of a
selectman or a budget Committee
Member has more power and influence than
any
hat pin sticker or sign would I now
press the red button to overturn the
itl so a better motion can be made thank
you representative Browns recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that most voters do not attend select
board or school board meetings and if I
know that most voters value their
elected officials positions and opinions
and Mr Speaker if I also know that this
information initiates thoughtful
discussion around warrant articles then
would I now press the green button to
ensure that this simple already
available information remains listed on
the warrant articles thank you Mr
Speaker the question is the motion of in
expedient to legislate on House Bill
1120 this is roll call vote if you're in
favor press the green button opposed
press the
seconds
[Music]
represent
bman all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house attend of
state of the
vote CH 64 and the affirmative 95 and
adopted the majority of the committee on
municipal County government to which was
referred House Bill 1125 an act relative
to requiring public notice and comment
at all County Commissioner and
delegation meetings having considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative
Laurel stavis for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the following resolution resolved
that it is inexpedient to legislate
representative Josh Joella for the
minority of the committee the committee
amendment is
H printed in house record 9 on page 52
the questions on the adoption of the
amendment are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted the Bill's on second reading and
open to further Amendment representative
stavis offers floor Amendment
0854 H printed on house record 9 on page
motion thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
I'm introducing floor this floor
Amendment today to correct a drafting
error in the original it simply deletes
wording in a previous amendment that
restricted public participation in
County Commission meetings to comment
only and not to questions the floor
Amendment before you today removes a
sentence that prohibited County
residents from asking questions during
the meeting and the members of Municipal
and County government view the ability
to ask questions as vital to the
openness and accountability called for
in RSA
91a they were rightly insistent this
sentence be removed this amendment
accomplishes that making the underlying
Bill even stronger I urge you to join
the majority of Municipal and County
government in voting to adopt it thank
the questions on the adoption of floor
Amendment 0854 H are you ready for the
question all those in favor say
I all those oppose
nay the eyes have it and the Amendments
adopted now we're on to the main motion
of a to pass as amended are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppose nay the eyes have
adopted
the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred House Bill 1242 an act
relative to the establishment of
countywide communication districts
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative Diane power for
the majority of the committee the
minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass repres representative Jim maiori
for the minority of the committee
representative Howard has recognized to
report thank you Mr Speaker and
honorable
Representatives hb1 1242 is all about
governmental efficiency in establishing
Communications districts so we can best
use the unprecedented Broadband funding
being made available by the Biden
Administration our state's rural
communities have struggled to access
this great program that started in 2020
with only a couple districts being
formed since despite the con
connectivity issues our rural
communities continue to face the major
problem is with how we currently
establish districts because it is
individuals towns starting this process
but the economies of scale work better
at the county
level Communications districts are not
tax funded but are funded by subscribers
and ensuring a large enough subscriber
base means operating at a county
level that is why one of the few
districts in the whole state is the
Carroll County communications District
because it is operating at an
appropriate scale despite the tedious
and difficult establishment
process opponents of this bill have
claimed that counties already have this
power which is false because the bill
explicitly refers to RSA 21 uh 47 and 48
which explicitly only gives County
governments uh the power over
unincorporated towns and not the whole
County this is only enabling legislation
meaning that counties are not forced to
create a Communications District but if
they do municipalities still have the
option to opt out the association of
counties is in unanimous support of this
legislation and I will hope you will
join me in helping our rural communities
and North Country have quality internet
access by streamlining this existing
statute thank
you representative McDonald's recognized
report thank you uh Mr Speaker uh hb1
1242 is the establishment of countywide
communication districts this bill if
passed with allow of County Wide
Community District districts but it's
going to do it's going to demand and
involuntary require all the communities
within that County to join that District
they will have the option to op out but
they still have to do that on their
own the governing body of
municipality would would be taxed with
taking the extra step to change and get
out of the uh the county agreement uh
the majority of the committee believes
this bill is unnecessary as current law
allows two or more municipalities to
create a communication District a prime
example of is a c County communication
District in which 16 towns have come
together to create the district it is
working both effectively fairly and
evenly for all its members I urge you to
support the majority position of itl
thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate and a division vote has been
requested this will be a division vote
seats
go
where
the questions on the majority committee
report of inexpedient to legislate on
House Bill
1242 representative Howard's recog uh
representative maiori is recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know Broadband applications are so
wide ranging they touch every social
determinant including economic stability
education social supports and civil act
Civic activity and if I know expanding
our communication District statute to
include counties as well as
municipalities we'll increase sharing of
planning construction operating and
maintenance of broadband Services
equipment and infrastructure for
residential and Commercial customers
alike and if I know public private
Partnerships between counties and
broadband service providers will
increase access to service that may
reduce customer cost costs and if I know
that this is only enabling leg
legislation that mun municipalities May
opt out of if they choose then Mr
Speaker would I press the red button to
overturn this motion so that a motion to
pass this legislation can be made thank
you Mr
Speaker representative lenot recognized
for a parliamentary inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know municipalities would
in a County already have the ability to
create Communications District
and if I also know this bill would allow
County Commissioners to un unilaterally
impose
communication districts
countywide if I know this bill would
force municipalities to have to opt out
of a communication District rather than
opt in and finally if I know that
Communications District should be
created from the bottom up rather than
than using uh utilizing top- down
mandated schemes would I now press the
green button to support the majority
position of itl thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate and this is a division vote if
you're in favor press the green button
if you're opposed press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
representative
Gibbs
there
have all members president had an
opportunity to
vote the house Lieutenant the state of
the
vote 173 in the affirmative 172 and the
negative the report is adopted I voted
on
that
the committee on Municipal and County
government to which was referred House
Bill 1297 FN an act relative to the
authority of municipalities to enforce
ordinances related to health and safety
having considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Len turkot for
the committee for what reason does a
member
rise to make a motion Mr Speaker State
your motion a motion to table HB
1297 representative Len turot moves that
house bill 1297 be laid on the table are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say
I hold
[Music]
seats
the question is whether to lay House
Bill 1297 on the table representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know each municipality has
developed their own specific zoning
regulations over many decades to suit
each municipality's needs and if I also
know this legislation would completely
negate and upend those Decades of zoning
regulations of every municipality within
our state what I now press the green
button to support the large 16-3
bipartisan majority vote of inexpedient
Speaker to table thank you represent MC
Williams is recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that New Hampshire is
currently in the midst of a housing
crisis where the median down payment of
20% to buy a single family home in the
granite state is
$71,500 according to bankrate.com and if
I further know that we are struggling
under the burden of 50 years of nimi
local ordinances many designed with the
intent to keep out new home buyers and
block residential development and if I
know that according to the marcata
center at George Mason University quote
New Hampshire only permits about three
new dwellings per year per 1,000
residents further quote local authority
to regulate housing density is based on
the state granted power to protect the
health and safety of residents but
localities in New Hampshire have imposed
restrictions on new development that go
far beyond these well-defined concerns
and have left the market unable to
respond to a growing housing shortage
end quote and
finally be in order finally if I know
that starting over with a blank slate to
rewrite our zoning regulations is
exactly what we need to address runaway
rents and affordability for firsttime
home buyers to rewrite new rules for our
rigged game of Monopoly our
municipalities have created through 50
years of zoning ordinance overreach
would I then press the red button and
instead support a vote for new rules for
new housing on behalf of future
generations of granite sters and Mr
Speaker I ask for a roll call thank you
can't the question is whether to a house
bill 1297 on the table if you are in
favor press the green button OS press
seat
[Music]
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 285 and the affirmative 65 and the
table so something happened a bunch of
times today we're going to address it
pis if you come up to do a pi and you
got a whole page you're not going to get
pi the majority of the committee on
Municipal and County government to which
was referred House Bill 1359 an act
relative to appeals of certain zoning
Decisions by abutters having considered
the same report the same with the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass representative Len serot for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the following
resolution resolved it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Diane power for
the minority of the
committee representative power offers
floor Amendment
0952 H which can be found in your seat
pockets and is recognized to speak to
our
motion thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of the floor amendment to House
Bill
1359 this floor Amendment simply adds
language that would allow a property
owner in a municipality who is directly
affected by a decision of the board of
adjustment to be able to file an appeal
at the local level this amendment is
important because the bill as written
goes too far and is overly
restrictive Mr Speaker it is important
to understand that a property owner can
in fact be affected by a zoning Board of
AD adjustment decision while not being
in a butter as defined in statute we
know that most towns in New Hampshire
are entirely on private Wells and septic
consider for example a large subdivision
that is granted a density waiver by a
zba and keep in mind that only abutters
are notified when the zba cases are
heard in this example without this floor
Amendment a directly affected non-ab
budding property owner with demonstrable
evidence that the density waiver would
negatively impact the shared aquafer
would not be allowed to file an appeal
at the local level however with this
floor Amendment a directly affected
property owner in the municipality can
file an appeal at the local level within
30 days since the zba must hold the
rehearing within 30 days to consider the
new information the maximum delay is 60
days and often much less to be clear
House Bill 1359 as written denies a non
abing property owner who was directly
affected by a board decision of their
due process rights for an appeal at the
local level this leaves as the only
recourse a prolonged court case in
Superior Court which will undoubtedly
result in Greater delays for any project
and increased expense for all parties
involved including effective Property
Owners the developer the municipality
and ultimately the
taxpayer Mr Speaker this amendment this
floor amendment is a common sense
provision that will protect the rights
of local property owners and give them a
voice for a rapid resolution at the
local level therefore I urge my fellow
colleagues to vote Yes to support this
floor Amendment and then the bill as
amended
thank you Mr
Speaker representative maor's recognized
amendment thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker I arise in opposition to the
floor Amendment adopting this floor
Amendment would defeat the purpose of
the important underlying Bill HB 1359 as
it has been brought to us today will be
a major step forward in facilitating the
housing um our state critically needs HB
changes the wording currently in statute
which is highly subjective to a more
relevant understandable definition of
what constitutes a butter when
developers go before zoning and planning
boards they are now open to time
consuming and costly appeals from any
person aggrieved as stated in current
law I think you will agree Mr Speaker
and colleagues that this could mean
anyone and frequently it does making
proceeding the with building projects
much more costly and in many cases
nearly impossible this amendment tries
to deal with the problem of changing the
language to any property owner in the
municipality directly
affected but the current statute's
language is also vague and can be
interpreted in any number of ways what
would directly affected mean could it
mean someone 10 miles away whose morning
drive would um would have them go one
more stop or pass by the the site could
it be someone 15 miles away who has a
difference of opinion with the applicant
unrelated to the
application and should the application
affect an aquifer Dees points out
statutes which clearly give the Pu
authority to overrule any local
regulation that would prevent Community
Water Systems from being squarely
regulated by the state uh excuse me um
would get that would um prevent
Community Water Systems from being
squarely regulated by the state alone if
necessary that provision has never been
used but it does exist so the aquit
question is a state question not a local
question clearly this amendment runs
counter to the spirit and intent of
1359 it further muddies Waters that are
already murky at best I urge you to
defeat this amendment so we can move on
to pass this leg important legislation
which was
bipartisan um from both Republicans and
Democrats on our committee thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the adoption of
floor Amendment 0952
H this will be a division vote members
seats
look
the questions on the adoption of floor
Amendment
H represent Powers recognized for a
thank you Mr Speaker if I know that this
floor Amendment would simply allow a
property owner in a municipality who is
directly affected by a decision of the
board of adjustment to be able to file
an appeal at the local level which would
take no more than 60 days and if I know
that this floor Amendment enabling
appeals by agreed Property Owners will
save developers municipal I ities
property owners and taxpayers alike
precious time and money by minimizing
court cases when I would I now vote Yes
to support the floor Amendment and push
the green button thank you Mr
Speaker representative maor is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that directly affected is
ambiguous and we cannot fully understand
who will be directly affected then Mr
Speaker would I please vote no on this
amendment thank
PE the questions whether to adopt four
Amendment
0952 this is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
B members president pres and an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 130 in the affirmative 224 in the
negative the amendment
fails we are now on to the main motion
pass representative cor is recognized to
report thank you m thank you Mr Speaker
uh it's important to understand exactly
what a zoning board of appeals does and
what a planning board does a lot of
people think that the zoning board
writes the zoning code that's incorrect
the planning board
does what about
it
okay it's important to understand what a
zoning board does a lot of people uh
mistakenly think that it writes the
zoning code it does not that's the
planning board the zoning board of
appeals has two purposes one is to Grant
variances from the zoning code where
Justice and strict application of the
letter of the law would not uh uh do
justice but the other thing is to serve
uh as due process or to hear citizens uh
protesting uh when the government has
not behaved correctly or fairly I'll
give you one particular example uh 6
years ago and there was earlier talk
about how long when you don't have an
appeal process court cases can go six
years ago I live in a residential and
agricultural District my nextd door
neighbor wanted to build a 26ft tall
industrial building building of 4,800 ft
so that he could run a body shop in it
in a residential area he went to the
building inspector the building
inspector has zero training in zoning
code or law he has training in building
inspection and that's good and
reasonable but it is his job to rubber
stamp or to stamp applications he said
yes you can absolutely put a 4,800 ft
bodyy shop in a residential Zone in the
front setback and in the side setback a
lot of neighbors were outraged by this
and we went to the zoning board of
appeals and that's another story and
I'll write a book on it someday um but
what happened is you've got a unelected
uh government employee who made a
decision that impacted other people to
the tune of hundreds of thousands of
dollars this and and at least the law
today says that we have an appeal we
have a right to petition our government
for redress of grievances and we did
this bill would say everyone up and down
this road who is losing 50 to $100,000
of property value unless they are
exactly next door or exactly across the
street has no ability to petition the
government there is even a hack here
that one of my lawyer friends pointed
out if a developer wanted to do
something underhanded um that would
drastically impact locals he could buy a
large piece of property subdivide it so
that he became his own abutter and there
were no other abuts and then no one else
would have the ability to petition the
government for redress of grievances if
the building inspector who again is not
trained in zoning gave him an illegal
building permit the goal of creating
more housing for New Hampshire families
is a good one I'm very open-minded to it
but this is a quick and dirty hack
saying government officials should be
allowed to break the law and citizens
should not be allowed to complain about
it so I
vote against the OTP and I encourage you
to as well thank
you representative lels is recognized
thank you Mr Speaker and thank you
colleagues all this business about a
Butters comes down to
definitions who's in the
butter who's an AG grieved
party
who is directly affected and who is not
directly
affected if you
have such an
expansive definition of a butter you
could have somebody in
California dragging
out a development that's much
needed if you have a very restrictive
definition
then you could have people who are
directly
affected who are not defined as an
abutter so that's what it all comes down
to we defeated the
amendment which seek to expand the
definition so that we would include some
of those people who are directly AFF we
we defeated that
this bill as
written strikes the current
language that says AG grieved
parties and leaves that kind of up in
the
air so as far as I'm
concerned we're better off with current
law which gives a little bit more room
then this bill as
written so please defeat the bill so we
much representative Len chot recognized
report thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
support of HB 1359
there are two parts to this bipartisan
leg legislation the first removes
extremely vague language uh from our
current rsas that allow an unlimited
list of individuals or parties to
unnecessarily delay an applicants
planning approval by using and abusing
or abusing the appeal process uh to the
adjustment the two phrases that we
eliminated in this uh language is an
agreed person and one directly
affected what does that mean what is an
grieved person what is one directly
affected under the current rsas somebody
in another County in another
state conceivably in another country is
allowed
to classify themselves as an agreed
person that in is part one of the
legislation that we eliminate the second
part
is it adds new and very spe specific
definition of the phrase directly across
the stream or street from to the abutter
definition and removing any doubts about
the interpretation now this definition
was uh devised by two individuals who
both have civil engineering experience
in it so although it may look a little
uh technical it is technical but it's
also very specific and this proposed
change came about while doing research
on this bill there were Supreme Court
case where there were very different
interpretations of What that particular
phrase of uh across the street of stream
meant so again while the new definition
looks uh complicated it's actually very
specific and it leaves no room for
interpretation now we've heard some
arguments um and I'm talk against a
couple of them one is the appeal process
process would not change the ability of
anyone who can demonstrate they are
directly affected by to
testify in the initial planning phase or
during the appeal
process the Selectmen the municipality's
board or like a local legislative body
for appeals any party to the action and
a Butters still will have the ability to
appeal now if there are individuals who
are not a Butters or the the list that I
just named they can certain testify and
they can also certainly influence um
some the long list of individuals I I
process now I mentioned at the beginning
of the bill that this was a bipartisan
Bill and it extends beyond the sponsors
of the bill which are bipartisan and
include individuals on the other side of
the wall and it also uh supporting
within the municipal and County
government uh Committee in somewhat
rather rare occurrence something we
don't see very often in Municipal and
County government outside parties and
those who testified I think every one of
them were all in agreement with this
legislation and I think you all received
a letter recently that included and
again these five individuals are rarely
on board with each
other the New Hampshire Realtors the
housing action in New Hampshire uh the
president Co Bia New Hampshire Planning
Association and the
nhma all were signatures of the letter
that each of you received in favor of
this legislation so ultimately the aim
of the bill is to reduce costly and
timec consuming frivolous appeals by
unaffected parties it will result in
quicker approvals faster construction
and therefore lower the overall cost and
these points should be very appealing to
those who believe we need more housing
at a faster pace make no mistake there
are many factors involved in our current
housing situation and most of them we
have no control over this legislation is
but a small piece where we can reduce uh
regulation reduce
bureaucracy and reduce unnecessary
delays I ask that uh you press the green
button and Mr Speaker I am going to
request a roll call vote thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of a to pass on House
Bill 1359 representative l shut request
a roll call is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
wel
the questions on the majority committee
report about to pass and House Bill 1359
and this is a roll call vote
representative Elward is recognized for
Mr
Speaker if I know that impacts from a
proposed land use project can be
experienced well beyond the boundaries
of an AB Butter's property that could
affect such things as noise traffic
water
quality water Quant
all of which could negatively impact the
use and the value of one's
property and if I knew that
testifying as a
witness at a public
hearing gives you no legal rights
whatsoever as opposed to being an
appellant and if I further know that the
bill is overly restricted Ive in that it
excludes non-abundant Property Owners
within the mun
municipality from filing an
appeal with the
CBA even though they can demonstrate
that their property is directly affected
by a decision of a planning board or an
administrative
officer and as such this bill unjustly
denies an aggrieved non abing property
owner their due process rights at the
local level so would I now vote
no and push the red button so that a
made representative Helen's recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
House Bill
1359 helps curve abuses to the zone
owning board appeal process and if I
know those those abuses lengthen the
appeal process and add great cost to
projects and if I know that it makes it
virtually impossible to build affordable
housing when that occurs then when I
push the green button to pass this
helpful
legislation questions on the majority
committee report about to pass on House
Bill 1359 there's a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppose press the red voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
of all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the
vote 265 and the affirmative 88 and the
adopted the Committee on Public Works
and highways to which is referred House
Bill 1253 an act renaming the Blair
State Forest in Campton as the Jane
Kellogg State Forest having considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved that it is
in expedient to legislate representative
Bill Boyd for the committee the question
is on the committee report of
inexpedient to legislator you ready for
the question all those in favor say I I
all those oppose nay the eyes have it
adopted the Committee on Public Works
and highways which which is referred
House Bill 1510 an act establishing a
commission to identify barriers to and
solutions for electric vehicle sales in
use having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved that it is inexpedient to
legislate representative Bill boy for
the committee the questions on the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legislator you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I all those
oppose
nay the eyes have it and the report is
adopted
okay the majority of the committee on
resources Recreation and development to
wases refer at as Bill 1142 an act
relative to requirements for Relevant
work experience before taking the exam
to be a septic designer or installer
having considered the same report the
same with the following amendment in the
recommendation that the bill ought to
pass with Amendment representative will
Darby for the majority of the committee
the minority of the committee having
considered the same and being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation that the bill be referred
for inim study representative Rosemary
rung for the minority of the
committee the amendment is
0653 H printed in house record 9 on
pages 52 to 53 the questions on the
adoption of the amendment are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I all those oppos n the eyes have it
and the Amendments adopted
now on the main motion the committee
report of a to pass with Amendment are
you ready for the question all those in
favor say I I all those oppose nay no
adopted the majority of the committee on
resources Recreation and development to
which is referred House Bill 1208 FN and
acts relative to permitting requir re Ms
for Timber harvesting operations in a
wetland having considered the same
report the same with the following
resolution resolved that it is
inexpedient to legislate representative
Dan Wolf for the majority of the
committee the minority of the committee
having considered the same and being
unable to agree with the majority Report
with the recommendation that the bill be
referred for interim study
representative Suzanne Vale for the
minority of the
committee for what reason does a member
[Music]
rise to put on the table
representative Rulo moves that house
bill 128 be laid on the table are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say I all those oppos nay the eyes
table the majority of the committee on
resources Recreation and development was
referred House Bill
1483 an act allowing subdivision
regulations concerning water supply
having considered the same report the
same with the recommendation that the
bill be referred for interim study
representative Robert harb for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority Report with the recommendation
at the bill ought to pass representative
Suzanne Bale for the minority of the
committee representative McGee is
report thank you Mr Speaker good
afternoon
everyone uh hb1 1483 protects home
buyers and
municipalities by enabling local control
over the assessment of water adequacy
for
subdivisions the bill does not mandate
any action it is
enabling putting this language in
statute brings Focus to the issue of
Water Resources in local
planning the department of of
Environmental
Services uh Water Division expert
testified that this bill was consistent
with the 2010 Water Commission report
findings where they found that there
should be additional statutory language
concerning the importance of water
planning uh at the local level for
Housing Development can the member
suspend for a minute I don't know where
everybody's going but made a little
noise we can wait go on
coffee
oh thank you sorry that happened go on
all
right yep continue thank
you so as I was saying there was a 20110
Water Commission report and the findings
in that report were that it was
important to put something about local
water adequacy into statute so that
municipalities would be looking at that
when they're considering
developments um but at the time the
commission was really unsure of how to
accomplish that and during the hearing
the expert that came in from de's water
department said that this bill would
actually be consistent with what they
were recommending at the
time um and this bill is the result of
two years worth of work and it was um
bipartisan in support and also in
sponsorship uh so I'm asking that we
take that action that was recommended by
first voting down this itl
motion hb1
1483 uh exempts Community water systems
and large groundwater withdrawals so
it's not overly
burdensome it keeps decision-making in
the hands of local planners rather than
trying to mandate a one-size fits-all
approach it treats water as a high
priority in the approval process like we
do with septic planning h
1483 is timely because as we've heard
today New Hampshire's being asked to
rapidly add housing stock to meet
growing
demand um this simple en enabling
legislation can make sure that local
boards don't skimp on getting
subdivisions
right uh this this bill asks planning
boards to prescribe minimum on lot
private well testing requirements to
assure adequate water body supply for
subdivisions as defined in RSA 674 colon
36 section 2 that is not the same as
requiring expensive hydrology studies on
every project the intent is to create
Clarity between the municipality and the
developer at the outset of the project
on what is needed to support multiple
new
builds while minimizing disruption to
existing Neighbors on private Wells we
may all know someone who has had their
well affected by a nearby development
this helps manage that issue the only
opposition to this bill came from the
New Hampshire Realtor Association and
they're a powerful Lobby and of course
they're concerned with anything that
might increase costs for their members
bottom line but we have an obligation to
protect the rights of our constituents
when it comes to essential resources
there's nothing more essential than
adequate water please vote no on the itl
because now is the time to get this
change onto the books and vote no on the
itl because this workable bipartisan
bill is favored by Town planners thank
you Mr Speaker and I request a division
vote
please representative harb is recognized
to speak for the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker first I'd
like to clarify I believe that this bill
is up from for interim study by the
majority not itl interim
study although this bill HB 1483 does
propose enabling legislation the
committee did discuss was it really
necessary could not subdivision
regulations of municipalities already be
adopted to provide the regulations
concerning water supply we receed no
legal opinion that it couldn't already
be adopted the potential cost developers
in a market where housing is drastically
needed was also a concern that if the
bill were to be passed the committee
also discussed water supply and quality
testing requirements prior to the
issuance of an occupancy permit for a
new residential home written testimony
was received from the commissioner of
the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services Dees that a
commission to study groundwater
established by chapter 1 76 of the laws
of 2008 found that among its commission
members which represented a diverse
group of stakeholders there was not a
consensus of whether local regulations
of groundwater withdrawals was
appropriate or
necessary it was for these reasons a
bipartisan majority of the committee
voted for an interim study to enable us
more time to look into this question so
we'd ask you to please press the green
button to support the by partisan
position thank
you the questions on the majority
committee report of interim study on
House Bill 1483 and this is a division
seats
e
letter
the question is on the majority
committee report of interim study on
House Bill 1483 members find your seats
them
representative veils recognized for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that the building of new
developments can and does affect the
availability of water in the vicinity
and if I also know that this might not
necess necessarily happen in a town like
mine like nasua but that it does happen
in many other towns in New Hampshire
and if I know that house bill 1483 is
enabling
legislation with bipartisan support
which means that no town is forced to
participate but if a town is having this
problem they can opt
in would I now press the red button on
the motion of interim study so that
another motion can be made one that can
get this legislation over to the other
chamber for consideration by the people
people who meet there thank
you representative Ren Zula is
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I
know that this bill requires a quote
water supply
study to be done prior to the
subdivision being approved and Mr
Speaker if I know that last year a
similar Bill required a requiring a
hydraul study prior to subdivision
approval was rejected by the
committee due to high costs long delays
and questionable
efficacy based on
Dees
testimony and finally no information was
provided as to what what this
proposed water supply study actually
entailed therefore would it not be
absolutely necessary for me
to to to have to vote for the committee
to exercise due diligence and Inter
interim study this bill to actually
determine what a water supply study
really
means hopefully it's not a hydrology
study in sheep's
clothing especially in light of the
housing shortage and already repres the
member will suspend I think you forgot
this was a pi pardon exactly this is a
pi I'm finishing right one sentence well
but yeah as as long as it's a question
folks
sometimes this job is
hard the question is on the majority
committee report of inm study on ill
1483 there is a division vote if you're
in favor press the green button oppos
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
resp
have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 182 in the affirmative 165 in the
on
the committee on science technology and
energy to which is referred House Bill
1036 relative to assessment of coste
effectiveness of the systems benefit
charge comes to us without
recommendation representative Harrington
moves out to pass and offers Amendment
H the questions on the adoption of the
amendment you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I all those oppos
nay
we're going to do a clarification vote
out
okay if you are in favor of adopting the
amendment press the green button if
you're opposed press the red voting
seconds
[Music]
represent
Ankerberg well members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend of the state of the
vote 176 in the affirmative 170 in the
adopted well when we do voice votes on
amendments we like voice votes because
they're fast and I know it's late I know
you're weary but
still make sure that you're there make
sure you put your voice out there cuz
that sounded like two to one the other
way all right now we're on the motion of
ought to pass as amended on House Bill
1036 representative McGee is recognized
report thank you Mr
Speaker the legislature sets policy and
Regulators carry it out in
2022 the house science technology and
energy committee brought to you an
urgent Bill to rescue the Hampshire
saves Energy Efficiency program we
brought that bill after the Public
Utilities Commission or pu had broadly
misinterpreted the legislative intent
around New Hampshire saves and opted to
stall a pending three-year program just
as it was about to roll
out the utilities and our small
weatherization businesses and all of
their workers held their breath hoping
that the state could do something to fix
what The Regulators had broken for no
apparent
reason that bill was HB
549 and as many of you may recall uh we
passed that at the Double Tree and it
was 343 to0 now I know many of you have
been in this house a long time very few
things pass without even one person
objecting but that was a good day and
the bill was quickly signed into law by
Governor cunu HB
549 put explicit guard rails around the
pu's administration of the New Hampshire
saves
program this bill offers to hand the
guard rails back to the folks who caused
that problem in the first
place uh HB 549 told the
puc how to handle the review process for
New Hampshire saves we defined the tools
that they would use in the review for
cost Effectiveness and uh one of those
tools the evaluation measurement and
verification study was to be conducted
by a professional uh under the guidance
of the Department of energy and the
joint utilities so we made everything
very very clear in statute the lines of
authority were defined and the chaos uh
that we had to fix with the pu's
handling of New Hampshire saves would
not be
repeated this bill puts conflicting
language into the statute and creates
competing lines of authority the there
was no compelling reason given in the
hearings for creating this competitive
statutory
language so please protect our excellent
New Hampshire saves
program uh Energy Efficiency in general
which is an excellent value for all of
us um there's no reason to give The
Regulators the authority to reset a
defined policy we set the policy and
they carry it out we did that for them
in a of 30 343 to Z I respect
respectfully ask that you vote no on the
ought to pass so that a better motion
can be
made uh and Mr Speaker I request uh a
division vote thank
you representative Harrington's
recognized speak for the committee
report thank you Mr Speaker um this bill
is u a little different but we need a
little background what the Imp purpose
of this this is the purpose of the
system benefit charge it's paid for 100%
by the rate payers and it's only one
purpose is to provide cost effective
Energy Efficiency projects for the state
period we heard a lot of people were
complaining about possible changes
because it would affect the utilities
they have to change the their planning
or it would affect the contractors who
install Energy Efficiency uh uh programs
they we don't really care that's they
they should be lucky they're getting the
money for this there's only one purpose
of this again it's for the coste
effective Energy Efficiency projects now
the Pu developed this and we had a lot
of different things going on but they
came to the Department of energy
actually came to us and asked us to give
us some flexibility in the future so let
me tell you how let me just read so I
tell you how flexible this is what we
what they're using right now is called
the granite state test and the as a
secondary one it's called The Total
Resource cost test this law would say
that when reviewing cost Effectiveness
for the program years through and
including 2026 the commission shall use
the granite state test as its primary
test and the total cost Total Resource
cost test as a secondary the commission
may consider modifications to the
granite state test and different or
additional tests developed through an
adjudicative process and approved by
them prior to commencement of any
trianal period and any provided any such
order is to be issued no less than 12
months probably the beginning of that
trienal period in which the test is be
to be applied so it gives them
flexibility to go back and know that
things change discount rates change
interest rates change ways of looking at
efficiency could change with times these
is basically this Grand state test was
developed it'll be 10 years by the time
the Pu gets to revisit it so that gives
them the flexibility to do that but it
also builts in the 12-month period so if
we feel that they've done a really bad
job that gives us an year to turn around
and say no don't do that so it gives him
flexibility to keep up with the times
until HB 549 was passed the Pu always
had the authority to set those par
parameters this is the first time we've
ever changed it so we're saying in the
future allow them the flexibility of
looking at possibilities because world
does change circumstances change maybe
the way we do Energy Efficiency cost
evaluation needs to change but either
way there's a safety Val in there if the
legislature doesn't like it it has him a
year to change it to to override that if
wano so please vote green on this thank
you the question is on the majority is
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 1036
representative Sweeney requests a roll
call is that sufficiently
seconded that's sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
e
the questions on the motion of a to pass
as amended on House Bill 1036 this is a
roll call
vote representative Wendy Thomas is
recognized for parliamentary
inquiry
Speaker are they
okay all good okay all right uh Mr
Speaker if I know this bill was
presented as providing flexibility for
the Public Utilities Commission to
modify cost Effectiveness tests being
used to approve the three-year NH saves
plan however the tests current Curr ly
being used have been agreed to by all
stakeholders and placed in statute to
provide Clarity and consistency to the
Joint utilities who are charged with
running NH saves so there is absolutely
no need to modify them and if I know
this bill contradicts existing statutory
language and brings confusion to Long
established process as to where
Authority rests for any cost benefit
analysis
and finally Mr Speaker if I know this is
exactly why the legislature stepped in
three years ago to set clear guard rails
protecting NH saves funding quantifying
its growth and limiting the pu's
authority to undermine the intent of the
state's Energy Efficiency programs when
we passed HB
549 would I now oppose the OTP motion by
pressing the red button so that a
different motion can be made thank you
Mr
Speaker representative V is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr
Speaker if I know that one prominent
State regulator said of the law under
debate here this afternoon and I quote
if you like rate payer funded Energy
Efficiency you favor a low discount rate
and if you think rate payer funded
Energy Efficiency is bad public policy
you prefer a high discount
rate which means that existing policy
can be manipulated to favor a particular
outcome which does a disservice to our
constituents but if I also know that
house bill
1036 provides a more Equitable framework
for determining the cost effectiveness
of Energy Efficiency
programs and finally if I know that good
public policy enshrines objectivity and
neutrality to the greatest extent
possible would I now press the green
button to guarantee that New Hampshire
gets the most out of its Energy
Efficiency Investments thank you Mr
Speaker the questions on the motion of
about to pass as amended on House Bill
1036 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor press the green button oppose
press the red voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
repr have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will
attend to the state of the vote 184 in
the affirmative 169 and the negative the
adopted the committee on science
technology and energy to which was
referred House Bill 1623 FN relative to
the state energy policy the bill comes
to us without
recommendation representative V offers
off to pass and moves Amendment
07828 printed on house record 9 on pages
70 will be a division vote on the
seats
for
we
the questions on the adoption of
amendment 082 H if you're in favor of
adopting the amendment press the green
button if you're opposed press the red
seconds
[Music]
all members pres had an opportunity to
vote house will attend a state of the
vote 182 in the affirmative 169 and
negative the Amendments adopted now the
motion is ought to pass as
amended and representative Kaplan is
motion
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker hb1
1623 represents a radical reversal of
long-standing energy policy which has
served our state well and also an
extreme departure from our
constitutional relationship to the
federal government its agencies and
regulations this bill
replaces the well-balanced current
energy policy which
integrates the private sector's need to
make a profit with the Public's need to
receive a beneficial service replaces
that with a protectionist anti-market
screed what one of the testifiers in our
public hearing called a spaghetti code
an unworkable jumble of
contradictory language and terms which
seeks to place its thumb on the
scale in favor of clinging like a
security blanket to traditional fossil
fuel energy sources and power generating
stations that don't even belong to
us this bill seems to be motivated out
of an irrational fear of an energy
transition that we've been we've been in
for quite a time
now and uh which has accelerated
recently due to our acknowledged need to
wean ourselves off of fossil
fuels are there examples of where the
government has come in and shut down
power generating stations and
destabilize the grid the fictional
situation which seems to motivate the
authors the proponents of this bill I
don't think
so as a matter of fact recently the
Biden Administration has responsibly
slowed down its ruem on several fronts
in order to not destabilize the
electricity markets and transition too
quickly this bill asserts quote unquote
the state's police power to protect and
defend power generation within our
state's borders in other words it would
have the state expropriate private
companies property and production for
the state's own needs not a good look
for the Live Free or Die
State this police power of expropriation
would depend on our department of
Energy's role in overseeing and
unwinding Federal rules and regulations
that would theoretically conflict with
this newly established internal energy
Market this is a role that the
department politely declined in our
public
hearings saying they didn't think it was
a viable or productive use of its time
and instead insisting that we continue
to defer to the independent system
administrator of our regional
transmission system the iso New England
in other words the the work that this
bill wants done can't be done by the
agency that would be charged with
carrying it
out this bill claims to be
Market based and neutral in terms of the
energy sources that it would seek to
develop but in the very same section
says that the state of New Hampshire
would seek to develop quote dispatchable
and reliable energy sources which is
code language to undermine renewable
energy development in our state it's
anything but market-based and neutral as
a matter of fact the market is clearly
spoken across the country and renewable
energy plus storage which is
dispatchable is the cheapest source of
new generation and is leading the charge
country by assessing by asserting the
state's right to set up and regulate
this new internal energy
Market this bill clearly stands an
opposition to the market forces it's
claiming to defend since we are part of
system and this bill intends to destroy
and replace this system with a top- down
state man
protectionist closed off energy
Market which hasn't worked anywhere in
the world where it's been
attempted we are not our own grid nor
should we seek to
be H 1623 is legally questionable
nothing says interstate commerce more
than a regional transmission and
distribution system it's physically
impossible electrons don't stop their
flow at the state line and it's
economically
nonsensical
we don't own the resources and we don't
have the scale in New Hampshire to
develop self-sufficient and affordable
energy systems on our
own nobody spoke in favor of this
bill the new the New England power
generators Association which
represents the power plants that this
bill has set its sights on called it an
extremist intervention an extremist
intervention I think that actually
understates it frankly I find it surreal
that I'm up here defend ending the New
England power generators against a state
takeover by the state of New Hampshire
put forward by mainstream legislators in
this
chamber because you see the New England
power generators they they get it we are
part of a energy transition that is best
managed on a regional scale under
Federal
oversight so please join me and turn the
rapidly dispatchable switch on this hot
mess this ideologically
motivated not ready for Prime Time Out
of Touch Bill and please
hit the red button for uh to pass so a
new and better motion can be made thank
call Representative V is recognized
Speaker we're
abundance energy is the foundation of
our
economy energy has become the lifeblood
of our
civilization try to imagine what our
life would be like if all the medical
devices in the hospitals around our
country and our world weren't able to
electricity imagine what our life would
be like without transportation without
communication without the ability to
manufacture
Goods all of that is provided by
energy and we're lucky that we live in
abundance but that energy abundance is
attack our state energy policy should
focus on three
principles and those principles are
reliability of energy
Supply use of any and all Energy
Technologies and the importance of
Market forces and Market
signals to keep that energy flowing and
affordable House Bill
1623 enshrines those principles
into State climate policy it replaces
the 88w run-on sentence of RSA 378 colon
37 which has been described by one of
our prominent State Regulators as a mage
of mixed
messages with a clear statement of these
principles but it does more than that
because as I said a moment ago
so we are under
attack the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission the North American Electric
reliability Corporation and many of the
country's Regional transmission
operators have been warning for some
time that closing existing power plants
before suitable Replacements are online
jeopardizes the reliability of our
electricity
grid
just two days ago the CEO of one of
those Regional transmission
organizations John
beay said this he said quote the
transition that is underway to get to a
decarbonized end state is posing
reliability the attacks are
Legion there are many of them out there
such as halting the permitting of new
liquefied natural gas export
terminals new EPA rules on particulate
matter that affect not only Power
Generation but Truck and Auto use as
well lower methane standards that affect
pipelines and power
generators State bans on gas stoves the
hb1
1623 acknowledges the responsibility of
the State of New Hampshire to guarantee
the health of our citizens by protecting
our supply of essential
power importantly it asserts our
constitutional 10th Amendment
sovereignty regarding any non-
congressionally mandated closure of a
power Generating Station it gives us
overreach it goes on to acknowledge and
establish that market forces are what
should drive the governance of our state
energy
policy HP
1627 would allow
a 23 I'm sorry would allow a generator
state who receives regulatory
information that would make it
economically infeasible for him to
continue to operation to operate to
approach our new New Hampshire
Department of energy and ask them to
investigate whether that's the case and
if it is the doe could ask the doj to
intervene on behalf of
that
generator this is important
legislation I ask for your support thank
Speaker the questions on the motion
about to pass as amended on House Bill
1623 representative Kaplan requested a
roll call vote is that sufficiently
seconded that is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
seats
for
C
back
the question is on the motion of ought
to pass as amended on House Bill
1623 representative Corman is recognized
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that when my friend
from eping introduced this bill in
committee he called it the New Hampshire
energy independ Independence
act but if I also know that we are part
of the iso New England grid and
inexorably tied into it and that energy
produced in New Hampshire flows out of
state and energy produced out of state
flows into New
Hampshire and if I also know that New
Hampshire produces no oil gas or coal so
that anyone that needs fossil fuels
whether it be a power generator or home
heating must be important in from out of
state then Mr Speaker would I be forced
to
conclude that New Hampshire energy
Independence is but a pipe dream and
press the red
button representative o is recognized
for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that our
current climate policy has been called a
malange of mixed messages
by one prominent State regulator and
that it should instead guarantee the
health and safety of our citizens by
power and Mr Speaker if I also know that
overzealous regulatory edicts can
directly affect a generator's financial
viability and might Force its premature
closure and finally if I know that this
bill asserts the Constitutional 10th
Amendment sovereignty of New Hampshire
to fight the untimely shutdown of a
power Generating Station what I now
press the green button to give New
Hampshire leverage to oppose regulatory
overreach thank you Mr
Speaker questions on the motion of about
to pass as amended on House Bill 12
1623 FN this is a roll call vote if
you're in favor press the green button
oppos press the red voting stations are
seconds
Shapiro
all members president had an opportunity
to vote the house will attend to the
state of the
vote 184 and the affirmative 168 and the
adopted a minute a
member for what reason does the member
from Manchester rise I'd like to place
the last debate in the per okay can't
I'd like to place the last debate in the
permanent Journal
please without objection so AED thank
you all right Mr
Speaker we have a majority report
Minority
Report um there is a oneon-one de the
amend Division and then we have a debate
on
okay the majority of the committee on
Transportation which was referred House
Bill 1118 an act relative to the
issuance of driv licenses for aliens
temporarily residing in New Hampshire
having considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
the recommend recommendation the bill
ought to pass with Amendment
Representative Steven Smith for the
majority of the committee the minority
of the committee on transportation to
which was referred House Bill 1118 an
act relative the issuance of driver's
licenses for aliens temporarily residing
in New Hampshire having considered the
same and being unable to agree with the
majority report the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to legislate
representative George sites for the
minority of the committee the question
before the house now is on the uh
amendment number 06 37h printed in
health record 9 on pages 51 to 52 are
you ready for the question there's a
debate on the amendment I'm sorry there
is a debate on the amendment the chair
recognizes representative uh Walsh to
speak I'm sorry representative Sykes for
a
pi oh he's doing both okay obser SES is
recognized the
speaker
Mr Speaker and
colleagues I want to begin by stating
that this bill began Life as a good
faith effort to clarify and even to be a
housekeeping
Bill uh that non-citizens could and how
they would obtain and when they could
obtain a driver's
license uh those folks include people
who come to work here
here and they include folks who come to
young people who come to study here and
all of my comments today will be related
to uh people who are here legally in in
all
circumstances
instead an amendment has been
introduced and for the moment I'm going
to keep my remarks to the amendment
itself the Amendment included language
that completely contradicts current DMV
rules and
practices So currently
ases who are here legally in the
country will
wait to hear have their hearing in some
cases those hearings determining their
permanent status can be delayed in fact
it can be
delayed 10
12 years even more in the meantime the
federal government has made it a is part
of the federal government to say if you
do not hear have your hearing within one
year of uh the time that you apply for
Asylum then you will be given a work
permit and then the DMV under its
current practice would say well you're
here legally you have a work permit you
should be able to drive and by the way
you can as long as you come down and you
take the written exam you take the
Practical exam and you prove that you
driver the
amendment changes all of
that um what's really unfortunate about
this is the amendment also is unclear
about whether people who have already
obtained their driver's license in this
manner will be able to renew that
driver's license and I want to tell a
very brief story about how as an example
how this works
practically we have a young person
living in the city of
Lebanon arrived here more than 10 years
ago his son began
School in in first grade I believe he's
in high school now his young daughter is
in the elementary school still he
volunteers his time with uh a couple of
the city's commissions so where resident
input is important and he works
full-time and supports his family he
works for a nonprofit agency that
provides services to the less needy
he pays more
than
40% maybe even 45% of his income for
rent so it's not an easy Row for him to
hoe but he's doing this and he's doing
well and he's thriving he has a driver's
license what happens when he renews next
amendment
the second part the second part of the
amendment that is problematic from my
perspective is that it
will
take it will require all
non-citizens to have their license
marked marked them as a
non-citizen now here's why this is in my
mind an anti-business measure because
right now there are lots of people who
come to work in businesses who have
skills who are
non-residents and they are able to do so
because they can get their driver's
license and they can get around and do
the work that needs to be done we
have institutions of Higher Learning who
are providing education to students who
come and they also receive a driver's
license under this mechanism they are
now going to have to go through
additional steps in order and put
citizenship on their driver's license I
would like to remind the house that we
have voted consistently over the
years not to accept the concept that
there should be a citizenship marker on
driver's licenses we have done so
consistently because of concerns privacy
concerns and so I would urge all of you
to um first off Mr Speaker I'll request
a division vote on this and I would urge
all of my colleagues to uh press the the
amendment the question before the house
is on the adoption of amendment
0637 the chair recognizes representative
amendment thank you Mr
speaker uh where to begin uh I'll start
up by saying that the previous speaker
was correct on what this amendment does
uh and that's the problem that's why we
have an amendment because the DMV is
actually giving um temporary work
authorizations to people with pending
Asylum and Refugee cases in spite of the
fact that they told me for months that
they were not now the bill does uh and
I'll get the actual words say that no
longer will these work authorizations be
recognized now why would we do this well
I don't know maybe it's me maybe it's
got something to do with the millions
and millions of people claiming Refugee
that are coming across our borders which
is going to be equivalent to tens of
thousands in the state of New
Hampshire maybe it's got something to do
with the fact that the current
Administration is ignoring uh treaties
and agreements we've been in since the
at least 50 years called the third safe
country agreement which means that only
a buding countries are we responsible
for accepting refugees you can't jump
six you can't get on a plane and fly
across the ocean to Mexico and then come
here and claim Asylum it's against our
own
laws maybe it's because because of
ignoring our third country agreement
it's reported that over 71% of the
refugee claims are not from even from
eligible countries of the 29% that are
maybe from eligible countries such as
Mexico they still need to prove either
religious or or or uh political
persecution to come here just to seek a
better life is not legitimate reason to
claim Asylum it's just not there are
other avenues for that to
happen I'll give you one more reason
that might might sway your opinion on
why we should be doing this on the
southern side of the Mexican border
there are tens and tens of thousands of
identities
identifications visas passports and
currency from right now they're Counting
about 180 countries from around the
planet why are these people leaving
their stuff in Mexico before they come
here because they don't want us to know
who they
are the bottom line is I'm not going to
get into the rest of the amendment
because this is the Comm the
controversial part of it but if you
truly believe the driving on our ways is
defined as a privilege and a privilege
reserved for our low abiding citizens
and the visitors or in this case the
people that actually are
completely uh vetted and adjudicated
through the Asylum courts please thank
please support the committee Amendment
thank you Mr
Speaker the question before the house is
the adoption of amendment
0637 this will be a division vote
members will kindly take their seats Mr
Speaker a roll call has been requested
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
vote
the house will come to order the
question before the house is on the
passage of amendment
0637 this will be a roll call vote uh
representative sites is recognized for a
parliamentary
Speaker if I know that my last name is
Vu or
sandal or perhaps
maputi that our family
those families they came here to gain a
better
life if I know that the amendment adds
two significant new requirements
including a citizenship marker which we
have voted consistently
against and if and a a Prohibition for
Ayes we're not talking about refugees at
this point we're talking about ases only
asy Le to get a driver's license while
they're waiting for their permanent
hearing would I now press the red button
so that another motion could so that the
amendment could be defeated the question
before the house is the passage of
amendment
0637 this will be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes the representative Walt
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I
know uh that no agricultural educational
or Hospitality or any other Visa Holder
will be affected by anything in its
Amendment if I further know that the
majority of Asylum claims are from
ineligible countries and based on the
volume of discarded IDs and currencies
at the border that all claims should be
adjudicated before P privileges are
given if I believe that work
authorizations are the way around to the
Asylum process which is overwhelming
which is overwhelmed by the millions of
claims then would I now press the green
button thank you Mr
Speaker the question before the house is
on the uh passage of House Bill 1118 as
amended the chair recognizes
did I is on the passage of the bill as
amended on the vote on the
the question before the house is passage
is the vote on Amendment
0637 uh this is a roll call this will be
a roll call vote if you're in favor of
the bill you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
button all V voting
vote
[Music]
e
okay if all members present had an
opportunity to vote the house will be
vote with a vote of 180 to 167 the
motion on the adoption of amendment
0637 passes the question now before the
house is on the motion of aut to pass as
amended the
member I have a motion to
make I'm
sorry uh Mr Speaker if you may I I would
like to make a motion or make a request
what say your request I move that I
would like to move that the uh previous
remarks on the amendment be put in the
permanent journal the bill over you have
to do the whole bill okay we'll make it
a package yeah yeah the question I
before the house is on the
uh ought to pass as amended now yeah uh
the chair recognizes now once again
recognize represent spikes PES for
inquiry yep
Pi thank you Mr Speaker colleagues you
heard my previous arguments I'm I'm not
going to repeat them but I will bring up
one final and additional point relative
to the bill as a
whole within the Bill's original
language I'm sorry he's speaking on the
bill I I get to speak that's fine you're
fine speak you're speaking on the motion
to AO pass as amended yes you're good
thank you Mr
Speaker so again I'm not going to repeat
the previous uh debate on the amendment
but I do want to point out that the
original bill in its original language
did have also a requirement that changed
some of the language of how the DMV
would
process um requests for non-residents to
to get their driver's licenses and they
changed the language from May to shall
and I would point out that during
testimony for that
we
heard very
determined very
forceful language and testimony from the
DMV of the problems that that would
create for them in administering that
and so for that reason alone I would
urge the co my colleagues to again I
request a division vote and that they
would push the red button the question
before the house is on the passage as a
amended of House Bill 11118 the chair
recognizes representative Smith uh to
motion thank you Mr Speaker this is
now so what I don't know why I put these
on I have nothing to read so here's what
happened somebody asked me a question
and I looked up a statute unless you
have an hour on your hands never do that
so I looked at the statute that provides
for licenses for people who are here
temporarily but legally and there was
some problems so it com is comprised
pretty much of three things one
identifying the people it applies to two
specific things that DMV should do to
make sure that they actually know how to
drive before we give them a license and
three the uh the terms so first these
were like if you took these things and
put them in a shredder and then pasted
them back together out of order they
were all over the place you'd have
something to identifi the person the
next one oh and by the way see if they
have a document that shows they know how
to drive by the way this applies to
people a mess I don't know how it
happened but we're going to fix it so
what I did was I went through this and
uh the stuff for identifying the people
that was easy goes in the first section
now we' kind of like to know they know
how to drive right how does a director
do that well previous legislature went
through the trouble to identify like
five different things things that the
director may look at doesn't say he
actually has to do any of them so he
took the time to identify these five
things and then the director can look at
it and go nah to much trouble and move
on not good enough so now it does say
that they have to do at least one of
these things now the DMV director was
concerned that some nefarious director
would pick the hardest of these five
things you know to kind of make it
really hard for these folks to get
licenses he can do that now matter fact
this is it's the way it's uh labeled he
may do all five of them now he can only
do one that's better not worse so we
reorganized the statute um some of these
folks who are here legally might not
have a Social Security number there was
no carve out for the statute that
explicitly requires one that's been
fixed they're here temporarily I know a
tech company that I worked for we would
get engineers in from overseas like two
years why would you want them to have an
Hampshire license well because our
insurance company on the company
Vehicles was a lot happier if they had
New Hampshire licenses so it makes good
business sense to do this the bill also
now requires that if they show a 2-year
Visa their New Hampshire license going
to be good for two years the director
has to sync up the duration of the New
Hampshire license with the duration of
their stay so it cleans it up it just
makes good sense and I hope you can
support it thank you Mr
Speaker the question before the house is
on the motion of ought to pass as
amended on House Bill
1118 this will be a division
vote roll call has been requested is
that uh sufficiently Second it is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
vote
clear
the question before the house is on the
motion of a to pass as amended on House
Bill 1118 this will be a roll call vote
the chair rep recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that this was a good
faith effort to try and clean up the
language and I agree with my colleague
about the efforts that he was making but
I also know that two very difficult and
for me problematic amendments were added
to that bill that go into all of the
things that I talked about where uh a
citizenship marker on the bill would be
would be required for these folks now
and where Ayes would not be able to get
a license to drive and if I know if that
happens how are they going to support
their family has to be the question
would I now vote red so that another
motion could be
introduced the question before the house
is on the motion of audit passes amended
on House Bill
1118 this will be a roll call vote the
chair recognizes the representative Walt
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh if I
know that this really shouldn't be a
controversial bill it just makes some
common sense corrections to law uh and
if I will always remember that driving
in New Hampshire is a privilege would I
button question before the house is on
the motion of aut pass as amended on
House Bill 1118 this will be a roll call
vote voting stations will now be open
for if you're in favor of the bill
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
seconds
for
if all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house would be
vote y
That's yeah on the motion of a to pass
as amended the vote
being uh 179 to 166 the motion carries
and representative Sykes is recognized
for a motion yes Mr speaker thank you I
move that the uh remarks from the debate
on the amendment and the bill be placed
in the permanent journal without
objection so audit representative Sweeny
is recognized thank you Mr Speaker
having Mr Speaker having voting on the
prevailing side on hb1 1412 relative to
court reporters I move reconsideration
no
vote the question before the house is on
the motion to reconsider House Bill
1412 this will be a Voice vote all those
in favor say I I all those in P poos say
nay
the
N7 in the motion
is defeated who swey is again recognized
for a
motion thank you Mr Speaker having
voting on the prevailing side of hb1
1623 I move reconsideration and urge the
no a division question before the house
is on reconsideration of House Bill 16
for 43 this will be a division vote 162
I Oppo correct that six House Bill
1623 uh members will take their seats
vote
yeah the question before the house is on
the motion to reconsider the vote on
House Bill
1623 if you're in favor of the motion
this will be a division vote if you're
in favor of the motion you'll press the
green button if you're opposed you'll
press the red button voting stations
seconds
[Music]
represent
M have all members president had an
opportunity to vote the house will be
vote with a vote of 165 yay 179 nay the
motion
fails representative Sweeney is
recognized One Last Time Mr Speaker
having voting on the prevailing side of
HB
1118 I move reconsideration and urge the
no
yeah the question before the house is on
the motion to reconsider
1118 this will be a division vote
seats
the question before the house is on the
motion to reconsider the vote on House
Bill
1118 if you're in favor of the motion
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the uh red button
voting stations will now be open for 30
seconds
e
repres
no have all members present had an
opportunity to vote the also be
vote with a with a vote on the motion to
reconsider 167 yay 178 nay the motion
yeah without objection the the remainder
of the bills will be special audit to
the regular place on the next week's
calendar Jia recognizes the majority
leader for a motion third reading motion
resolve that the house now adjourned
from the early session that the business
of the late session be in order at the
present time and the reading of bills be
by title only and resolutions by caption
only and that all bills ordered a third
reading be read a third time by this
resolution and that all titles of bills
be the same as adopted and that they be
passed at the present time and when the
house adjourns today it be to meet
Thursday March 14th at 9:00 a.m. 10 oh
we changed it 10:00 a.m. 10:
[Music]
a.m. take V on
the question before the house is on the
third reading motion all in favor say I
I oppose nay the eyes have
[Music]
it we have one unanimous consent will
the members please keep it the noise
down uh the chair recognizes
um the house will be in order so the
member can speak
it's the only unanimous we consent we
have so you may want to listen to our
friend from do thank you Mr
Speaker so please folks one month ago
February
[Music]
7th an American Helicopter went down in
California the Marine crew all died in
the
crash
ordinarily uh I might not speak about
this on the house floor but the but the
pilot of the
helicopter was a Captain Jack Casey of
Dover um I didn't think I knew Jack
Casey and indeed I didn't but I know his
father and his sorry his uncle and his
grandfather uh and so I i' just like to
read a few remarks from his
obituary which I cleared with his
grandfather is something that he would
appreciate being done
so as I say ordinarily I wouldn't do
this but when Jack took the oath of
office and put on that Marine Corps
uniform he's not just a resident of do
anymore now he belongs to all of us so
if you will just wait a second while I
up I have to say when I when I attended
the Wake there were thousands of people
here
as a leader he would carry he would
carry people's burden and help them find
a solution when in doubt flat out drama
was not his in his vocabulary leading by
example in a calm convincing manner he
did the right
thing whether or not someone was looking
he was a fiercely loyal husband
son brother and friend our universe has
lost a precious rare amazing Soul honor
him by living life to the fullest be
like
Jack thank you Mr
Speaker also have a moment of silence in
memory of Captain Jack Casey United
Corps
the remarks of our friend from do would
be placed in the permanent Journal thank
colleagues representative Osborne moves
at the house standing recess for the
purpose of introduction of bills and
Road Bill amendments and Road Bill
reports vacate motions in receiving
messages are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I oppose nay the
eyes have it the house is in recess
until Thursday March
14th at 9:00 a.m. I'm sorry 10:00
in